all right hey what's going on it's Bill
burrr and it's time for the Thursday
afternoon just before Friday Monday
Morning podcast and I'm just checking in
on you checking to see how your week's
going and uh we got the video going so
that means I have a very special guest
and uh this guy I don't know what to
tell you about this guy other than he is
when you think comedian's comedian
comic's comic whatever you want to say
the guy that makes all the other Comics
stop what they're doing stand at the
back of the room to see what this guy's
going to say um he's got a new special
out called
hashtag was it cancel Holtzman The One
and Only The Legend Brian Holzman thank
you thank you very much yeah you like
that
dude um I don't know what to say to you
man I have been the first time I saw you
was when I was just a wead um the late
90s I went down to The Comedy Store and
I saw you on stage and you had this
leather jacket on you were telling the
crowd was made out of baby
seal and that you you had AIDS you took
a bath and you got over it just just the
most irreverent craziest and yet
you were still killing and uh I don't
know it's just an honor to have you on
here and it's an honor to promote your
new special thank you thanks for having
me uh Bill Bill yeah you can call me
Bill can I call you William yeah you can
call me
William so um
let's get into it man you're you're
you're uh you're living in Texas or
you're your Cal your little little I
went out to the new Mothership Joe
Rogan's new club to Mother Ship I've
seen it yes you were there quite the
joint yes uh he modeled it right after
the the The Comedy Store for good reason
you know why fix it if it's not broke it
works really well and but I've uh and I
go back and forth yeah how how do you
like
Texas yeah I go back and forth that's
why I go back and forth no Texas is
great but uh it's Texas I know Texas
doesn't have state tax okay so I get
that aspect of it but I feel like if you
if you weren't born there when that
summer heat comes I mean it's bad enough
out here but that that that like
I feel like I'm paying state tax out
here for no
humidity like that that or
mosquitoes oh my God or like
hurricanes and all of that like that's
really like kind of something that
fascinates me right now where people
think that they're going to move
somewhere and all of these these
problems are not going to affect them
and it's just like we're all in this
we're all in this together so it's just
like I don't know where you going to so
I'm just like I'll just stay
here I'm I'm enjoying the amount of
people leaving California I hope more
people do it yeah cuz I'm going to stay
you know they say I want to move I want
to move to a state where my vote counts
well you better bring a snow shovel you
know well I I don't think it counts
anywhere it's always gonna be it's gonna
be right it's gonna be yeah does
it really count it's a good point does
it count anywhere you move no I don't
think it does because when when when
even like when when liberals oh my God
we're so much better than you we even
when they're just overtly fixing things
like the last two like uh elections I
always say this they Bernie
Sanders won the popular vote and they
were just like yeah no we're going with
the company man you got Hillary whatever
this bozzo's name whatever the
hell this what's his name Biden Joe
Biden I'm out I I I I sleepy Joe yes
sleepy Joe it's nice way of saying he
has dementia and he's right next
to the red phone but that's not a
concern right right that's not a concern
for people uh what have you been up to
as far as like uh uh touring you out on
tour um no I'm just hanging out at the
mothership I guess uh I'm it's the lazy
way to tour okay you know I can stay
there and uh you know and uh not cuz you
know how airports are today if you can
is that what it is is that why you don't
to the road because you are to me no you
got to put asses in the seats and I'm
not there yet okay and until which I
don't understand how you're the funniest
guy out there well
uh uh it's all on me you know it's uh
it's you know uh maybe someday you know
that's what the hope is but I'm I'm
enjoying the ride you know up until then
I you I mean no I get what you're saying
and I don't want to go to some nowhere
land no place and you know you've been
to all of them they drop you in the
middle of nowhere and you get there and
you go why am I
here oh yeah you kind of got yeah that's
something that you know those I
mentioned like like uh there's certain
people that just great at the business
and okay at comedy and then there's guys
that are great at comedy and then
they're not good at the business so yeah
you're not you're not
so if you guys you know it really is you
know that's what really what it is if
you want to you know until somebody
holds my hand or right you know cuz
that's what's funny cuz like that's the
same I think in all art forms and
everything it's like are like this is
this you okay this is the greatest
guitar player this is the greatest
painter whatever it's like are they
really or did they just have the
greatest hype I mean they're still good
but like the hype machine there's always
this guy around the corner going
dude there's this guy Two Towns over man
he could play with that guy plays
blindfolded or uh he's just you know we
just where is he stays to himself he's
at work that's you he's at work
yeah do you ever try to get better at
the business are you content no I'm
doing now I'm reaching out I reached out
to you to be to be on here I reached out
to Bobby Lee and I which I reached out
to uh Theo vau and I uh Joe Rogan knows
I'm interested in doing his podcast mhm
and uh so I am you know I'm the kind of
guy that doesn't like to ask for
anything you know I'm from Back East
what does that mean that means you just
uh you don't want to ask for anything
you just you know how's that working out
it doesn't work out very well especially
in Show Business here's another thing
back here's another thing back e like
don't don't be getting all happy
don't be getting all happy like dude
there is just so much trauma back East
you have to get away from it not saying
forever but you got to stand back and
look at it and then finally see it and
then see how it affected you and try to
like cuz who the was you know I'm
not happy and I don't ask for help I I
and then I take it out of my children on
the holidays it's just like stupid my
parents took my brother Bruce and I the
uh Westberry Music Fair back in the day
mhm and uh Long Island right and it was
uh how Lindon remember Bonnie Miller yes
my mother was love that guy oh yeah that
was he was the headliner a man he had a
nice full head of hair he had a nice
mustache yeah they liked that oh he love
to have Lon looked like he had a colog
and uh and uh he was the headliner he
played the clarinet and then uh and then
uh before he he he uh the first comic
was Bob lemon an older gentleman mhm and
then it's when I realized you can be
very senior and still do comedy and was
great his name is Bob lemon he's
probably gone now and then guess who
came up after Bob lemon buddy hacket
buddy and murdered and murdered right he
told the guy the kid in the front row
with his parents that your parents ever
find your MTH jacking you knowbody
hacking right right and it was great
then how ly Lyon wait is this is this
the one that's in the round right
Westberry in the round I haven't done
that in years that was like amazing to
perform there because I saw uh H Mandel
did a special there and absolutely
killed so it was amazing to be there so
I never knew where you were front so you
grew up cuz you don't have an accent I'm
I'm from Long Island you're from Long
Island and what year did you come out to
you're from Boston I'm from I'm no but
I'm from the uh the I'm from the suburbs
well I was too they don't you know they
don't make movies about the suburbs of
Boston they make movies about people
from you know South E Charles toown
Dorchester like that's where the story
are um but I I grew up in the uh the
suburbs are fantastic pond hockey street
hockey playing hoop and and pick like I
grew up in a very like uh a very nice
town I didn't have to deal with that
that and you left your job you left
your day job to do comedy I did and it
worked out wonderfully I never left my
day jobs
because Shaw was spoiling me mhm every
night of the week I'm doing comedy at
the world famous comedy store in Los
Angeles every night I could still do a
day job but you know as Jay Leno always
says the thing that will spoil a comedy
career it's a day job oh a good day job
so what you working on airplanes right
he working for United Airlines for 17
years and I was working at the Aerospace
Corporation in ela gundo this is what
the he was doing during the day and
then he would go down to The Comedy
Store and you were better than all of us
and I would you know at the I was uh
they had they had uh Aerospace
Corporation it's a funded government
space you know and uh I was a security
guy at the gate and at the end of the
time I was there you could have showed
me a McDonald's gift certificate I would
have let you in they had contractor
badges they had the military badges they
had like 20 or 30 different
you is tell you can say on this
badges then after that I got a job in
Manhattan Beach uh in the police
department cuz you know I had an act you
know my act when you have an act like
this and you lose a job you go out and
get another job no one's going to tell
me to that's keep you don't don't quit
your day job I know that I know that I'm
getting another job no one has
to tell me that you know but I was
spoiled she spoiled me you know where
else do you want to do comedy and it was
that thing in your head that you want to
be discovered in La if you know she
ruined my life I came down here from San
Francisco from United I said I'll go to
The Comedy Store and I'll get this thing
over with and they'll tell you if you're
funny or not or tell you you know Al so
what do you mean get this thing over
with like what were you thinking like
well I you know comedy we grew up with
some of the biggest comics in the in the
business you know it's you know I guess
I'm very humble you know I wasn't like
you know I can do you know I you know so
you thought it was this silly idea you
had and you were like all right I wanted
to just put it to bed I didn't I wanted
to just do it and see if they told me
get the out of here at the comedy
store then I could say I didn't try okay
I went to the Mecca and I and she and
then you see what happened now
for my whole life yeah
why well sometimes you you sometimes
don't you sometimes uh
Envy just regular people 100% that's
what I say 100% we always got to be
thinking we always it's not like playing
in a band where you can go up there like
a on crack and play the same
song for 30 years and
everybody's like oh oh oh oh you know we
got a different audience every night we
got a different head our head is
different every night every you
know it's it's it's the most uh if you
if you break it down it's the most
craziest you know to make somebody laugh
it's the and it's also a gift I mean
it's like making but I think I would go
nuts if I cuz um I feel it's just how
life is like if your life is really busy
and it's really loud like I feel like
what I do for a living is loud I would
say so you know what I mean like I'm
loud the crowd's loud whether they like
it or not it's just loud and then so
then I crave after is quiet I don't want
to I I don't want to hear me I don't to
hear anybody else I just want to go sit
somewhere and like when I'm driving in
the middle of
nowhere um to some of these cities you
know the places in between that I just
sit there going like if I just lived out
here right it would be nice and quiet I
got an old pickup truck I could just
drive these roads there'd never be any
traffic and if I could just live
like this little life so what I've kind
of started to do is I just do that in La
like I try to keep my life like a little
like f mile radius like if this there's
a restaurant outside of that I'm just
like I'm sure it's great I'm I'm not
going I'm going to just there's enough
you want to stay on base exactly I
want to stay on base so like I I know
where I'm going to get my Italian meal I
know where I'm going to get my my my
tacos from I know where I'm getting my
coffee from my gyms over here and I just
want to be like uh like I definitely I
definitely uh understand that but having
said
that um I've always wanted people to
know who you are because I think you
know it's one of those you know I don't
think you got to be like you know work
on your brand and all of this stupid
that people say now yeah I'm a
little bit too old for that you know
what I mean I think what you're the way
you're doing it is beautiful you know I
don't want to force it I have this thing
in my head I've always had it you've
heard it a lot of times a lot of people
have said it if it's meant to be it's
meant to be right and doing standup
there's no hiding you're you're so
exposed everybody's it's the only job
where everybody knows how you're doing
it yeah yeah per
second as it's going and you know
exactly when it's starting to like uh
yeah it t and it takes forever to learn
how to ignore that control it or
whatever is that your brand right there
this is uh this is my new uh
no now knowing you you bought something
there like N9 years ago and you just
kept the bag and now you're walking
around like a crazy person Rose for a
shopping bag okay I brought you this
book you I know you're uh you're a
director now so I know you're interested
in literature and books my sister sent
me this book and holy cow I've directed
a few things but I don't know how what a
book this is you you you'll read this in
5 minutes they're making a movie on it
killers of the flower moon this is uh
this is a story of uh these Indians they
gave him the lousiest land they could
find in Oklahoma then they found out
there was oil on the land so then the
white man came in and started killing
killing I've heard that story oh you'll
read this in 5 minutes it's a page
Turner dude I can't I can't get rid of
the books man every time I finish a book
somebody gives me like two more I will
definitely read this this this you know
want to see how I read this is how I
read I go like this I just look up okay
300 how many pages is this no you're a
reader you're a reader I'm not dude you
know why I like to read is it eases me
into a nap oh yeah yeah wait okay 300 24
pages no that's not it you never know
when the end of the book 321 pages I can
do this I wish the printing was bigger
but there are
pictures wow all right forget it no no
no no no I'm reading it a masterful work
of literary journalism crafted with the
urgency of a Mystery Dude the world is
just full of so many sick people it's
the craziest I'll tell you what like do
you know why I started read finally read
again why would you give me this cuz
they always tell us we will never forget
so if you put this on your nightstand or
on the refrigerator you will never ever
forget bill I don't I don't want you to
forget that's they don't want us to
forget right you know and in 100 years
or 200 years all these cities and towns
are going to have these
old steel gers all bent to and
people are going to go what is that for
what is that for why do they have that
there you know people's I was at work I
said uh to my young co-workers I said do
you know who Paulie Shaw is you know how
many of them said no and he's still
alive so what does that have to do with
911 I just thought that's a that's a
keep what that's a keep know this is a
Keepsake why would I want to look I
don't want to look at this what do you
got in there Pearl Harbor that's
a nice photograph I don't want you don't
I don't want that that's the Empire
State
Building That's a classic photograph
black and white you think about it you
I'm I I think I'll just take the the you
know the second
genocide before I come I look around my
my house to see what things I can give
to people you know what do they call it
uh uh regifting regifting yeah dumping
the you don't want on me the fact
that that's in your house your wife like
wine yes oh then this is this is fine
Merry Christmas Merry Christmas thank
you look this everybody we're
celebrating Christmas in July I don't I
don't drink so Bri I don't either I mean
I do but okay she'll like that all right
we'll take I'll take the wine in the
book I'll put the rest on a gift
certificate never come empty-handed no
but uh yeah so so uh so I am reaching
out I got this special and we'll do
another one at c c a certain point we
will and
uh and I'm I'm just I'm as excited about
the comedy as I did when I first uh
started in San Francisco I remember
that's amazing so what year did you
start
1988 1988 and the first thing I talked
about was my grandmother and I just
talked about my grandmother and they
laughed and everybody laughed and it was
just fun it was just fun the whole way
what did you feel like when you got off
stage you got laughs and you were
walking out to the car afterwards what
what was that feeling like it was just
it was just uh it was just a fun fun
feeling to just get up there and talk to
the people without a lot of preparation
mhm and tell and the truth is always the
funniest has that always been your style
did you just naturally know to just go
up there and start talking or just had
that ability right I I I I I'm just real
comfortable and um I know uh I know what
I want to say and uh would you think
about it while you were at work working
on planes and like that oh yeah
yeah I would uh were you one that jotted
it down or could you remember once in a
while jotting it down I'm not really a
big
uh you know sit down for 2 hours a day
and manufacture comedy that wouldn't
that wouldn't be Holman I tried doing
that it was just like okay so what's
funny it's just like yeah it doesn't
work it isn't funny happens right do you
want to tell the audience an abstract
bit that you came up with or do you want
to say something that the whole audience
can identify with immediately
that's a great question cuz I don't
think there's there's uh a wrong answer
there because I love the people that can
come up with the abstracts like stepen
right stuff I mean it's just
unbelievable I saw him at the Mother
Ship I bumped into him he was looked at
him just Ste oh yeah dude that guy has a
book out called Harold you have to read
oh yeah oh it's like I don't even know
how to uh what was I describing it as uh
uh catcher and the Ry uh on
mushrooms like it is it is wild like the
well the two best books I read this year
were were uh Jim Carrey's book and uh
and um um Steven Wrights two comedians
as far as like books that blew my mind
I'm sure this one this is I got a family
vacation coming up this is a nice this
is good uh sit on the umbrella at the
beach oh man and just read of the crimes
where you going to
go uh we always go back to uh we go back
East you know where everybody tells It
Like It Is East you know and the West
yeah there's no there's no uh nobody
lies back East man tell you right off
the when a contractor says it's going to
be done in 3 months he gets it done in
two months and 29 days tell us a
story when I saw you in the airport we
saw each other in the airport with the
masks
on oh yeah did you recognize me or I
recognized you I think we both
recognized each other no I came walking
up and you came walking up going hey
how's going on I was just looking at
like who the is this guy we had
masks
on or I know I was looking at I I was
talking to you when you were looking
like who the is this guy and then I
fin pulled down I go oh it's Bill bur
you're like oh
how are
you yeah
yeah that's already looking like an odd
time when we all wore masks it just
didn't work I can't believe it
to this day how I can't believe it
didn't work cuz you know you got
everybody's got to be pulling in the
same direction it was doomed wearing a
mask not wearing a none of it was going
to work none of it was going to
work cuz everyone was doing what
everyone was living their best life so
that was there was it you know at the
end of all of that you know what I
feel bad for I felt bad for the doctors
the doctors yeah cuz I don't think
anyone was really listening to him even
people who said they were listening to
him were still doing they shouldn't
have been doing and I just remember
picturing them Working Day and Night the
fact that they came up with anything
within a year is amazing and
then they would just sitting there like
why are we trying to save these
all they're doing is just like
on us it's kind of like you
know when when you have like you know
like a third set at a comedy club and
it's just a the crowd doesn't
give a three shows a night yeah and
they're just being and you're
just sitting there going like you know I
like I flew all the way out here I I I
could have just stayed home I didn't
need to do this like I I kind of
I felt for doctors and all of that you
know three shows at night in your day
job would you ever go to your day job
come home and then go back to your day
job the same day I know the comics they
make more money when they do more than
one show a night but it's it's kind of
nutty you know let's do this
three times the second show the second
show was the one that always would get
me the first one I wouldn't give a
cuz it was so long I would actually be
loose and Goofy right and then the third
one's the last one so you're like okay
no matter how bad this sucks I know it's
over in you know 45 minutes to an hour
the second one when you're going back up
there and here we go again and knowing
you still have to do it yet again oh and
what about sometimes don't you forget
yet if you said it already well
fortunately the when I was doing three
shows in a night I would try to keep it
roughly in the same order but as I got
more and more seasoned and I was just
talking and doing whatever then it
started I had to do a lot did I talk
about this already like I don't they got
me working they got be working from
6:00 to 2: a.m. tonight just up here
like empty in my brain um my
favorite comedy clubs though were and
what I do love about Joe's Place is I
love a com club that gives you the
choice on whether or not you want to go
out and see the crowd after your show I
like right I heard I hear all the horror
stories bill yeah go out there and meet
the people no I don't mean that I mean
like you didn't have a good set or you
got into it with some guy and you have
to get off the stage and then walk
through the crowd waiting to get
suckered or get yelled at who tells you
to do that the club owner the design of
the club because the Green Room is in
the back of the room is what I'm talking
about I'm not talking about meet and
greets I'm talking about about how the
genius of having like the the original
punchline in Atlanta you walked off
stage and you walked into a
green room and if you just stayed in
there no matter what the happened
out there left all right but these other
ones like the very first one I ever did
Nick's comedy stop it's like you got off
stage and they had to walk the gauntlet
of these drunk people and you know you
if you got into it in a bad way then
you're coming off stage your eyes are
adjusting to the light it's all dark
like it was uh you know it just it was
it was not comfortable to say Le then
then Nick you just sat in the back and
people just walk by you going to the
bathroom hey you sucked or say
something now or just you know
or or they like the show and they would
still come up to you and they ask you
just a bunch of dumb questions with that
it's just all sucking your energy for
like the next show where is like I love
the punchline in Atlanta you just you
just went into that that place
and just sat there and just closed your
eyes you know let everybody leave or
whatever and then you could recharge for
the next one because it's not the second
Show's crowd's fault that you got tired
because the design of the club was
up you know so you're like doing
one show now that's all you do now is
one show a
night um yeah I I uh I'm too old for two
shows or three three I look if I'm doing
45 minutes I could do three standing on
my head but if I'm going to be doing
like an hour and 1550 an hour and 20
then yeah I don't want to do like
three in in a row it's like why don't we
just get them all in one place at the
same time and I'll do it's much more
efficient I think I just did four
weekends in a row and I'm just like I I
can't like uh that's a lot of work
that's a young man's game it is it's a
young man's game and uh and it's another
thing too is I like being old getting
old I'm en really enjoying it and I like
how your role in society changes where
like now you know do you know I did what
I did and now I cheer on the younger
people it's it's fun what are you doing
there sunny boy oh that's fantastic you
stick with it you don't listen to the
jerks I'm going to sit here and read my
paper see if anything funny how
sensitive your ears get as you get older
oh my ears are shot I got I got tontis
really bad in this one I probably have
it in this one too but this one rings so
loud that I can't hear this one but I
remember hearing this story of a guy he
went to the doctor and was like Doc I'm
going to blow my brains out you
got to get this just kill the ear and he
killed the ear and he goes all right
how's that he goes now it's in this ear
cuz he couldn't this one was just
ringing louder it was drowning it
out I don't know if he then killed
himself that's uplifting so # cancel
Holtzman is the entire special out are
we just putting Clips out like how what
are we doing with this thing the whole
the whole special is out on The Comedy
Store YouTube channel M it's also on my
uh YouTube channel MH so if somebody
wants to watch it they can just punch in
cancel Holzman dcom and'll take h o l TZ
M and it'll take you right to uh my
YouTube channel and then I put some
clips out I have a guy that makes clips
for
me well dude I think you're uh so what
should I do what should where should I
go from here what would you oh my
question be what do you want to do do
you want to sell put asses in the seats
that's put asses in the seats you know
that's the whole nine they always want
to know we'll give you 50% of it cheats
if you get their cheats we'll
give you know and when they're coming to
see you that's half the battle they know
what they're going to get you don't have
to you know you don't have to convince
anybody you know no it's your job to
lose them once you get a follow in the
beginning no in the beginning it's you
have to get them right and you're
worried about am I going to get at him
and then once people come and they know
who you are then the fear is am I going
to lose them are they going to come back
again was that good enough did that suck
or whatever so I don't know if you have
a I don't think that's I don't think you
have that problem no I do no no I do you
you you would you do a stadium back East
but can I tell you something back East
where everybody's you know what
they're thinking they say it not
like these West Coast PE the lying is
all this's the deal lying is all in the
west racism is all in the South and in
Boston and then people who tell like it
is the the be East and then uh
everyone in the midwest oh they're just
nice they're just it's all
it's all nonsense huh yeah i'
I've been to Fargo they weren't going
like oh you bet you they weren't saying
I understand that you know but I mean it
just it's
not that is kind of funny you know I was
actually talking about um
cuz I'll tell you oh as far as like
racist one of the most racist
places I've ever been to is New Jersey
oh yeah New Jersey is just
Staten Island yeah and it's just like
but for some reason they haven't had
enough of a major
incident that that I don't know they
just kind of get away I mean it's
insane like just the way that
they respond to like different
material
um maybe Boston is at the same level but
I'm just New Boston is no worse than
new Jersey and people always go
what is it what is it about
Boston and I always just go well where
are you from oh yeah people aren't
racist there like how do you do it are
you sweeter with your racism
like how did you guys cure
racism you live in an all white town is
that what it is so everybody gets along
with each other is that like I've just
I've kind of um yeah there just there
there's there's uh
lot there's a lot of characters out
there and the media doesn't help they're
making money on making people upset how
about Hollywood I want to tell you
something all the racist the most
racist I ever thought I got from
Hollywood that's the funniest
thing like their idea like that they
they're the
beacons you know what I mean and it's
like you're not you guys have actually
been racist prop propagandists for the
longest time like all my ideas
about every race of people came from a
room full of white writers writing this
and you didn't even notice how
racist it was now I go back cuz
I watch all these old movies like this
is like insane every role for
someone nonwhite drug dealer rapist all
of this crazy and then they
have the nerve to go back like like
Hollywood right now is just like like
becoming integrated in 2023 and they've
been walking around acting like the the
the the chosen ones as far as
white people like sports integrated 60
years ago and I feel like
Hollywood right now is where baseball
was in like
1958 where you had like Roy
Campanella uh Jackie Robinson and Willie
man they got three of them there's three
three of them so um yeah so I find like
what do you it's just funny out here
them saying how racist Boston is
and I'm like as opposed to what the
you guys have been putting out what do
you think about the strike they're up
against an organization that can figure
out how to pay somebody one sense I know
that's going to be a tough that's going
to be you know what when I I find what
is is amazing about it is it's no
different than any other uh like that's
what I hope people get in red States
when they look at it cuz oh my God
Hollywood's this bleeding heart blah
blah
no the only bleeding out here is from
your throat like you see what these guys
are doing like they are they are
gangsters and this city is not La La
Land This is the toughest City I
ever lived in New York as tough as New
York was you just wasn't all consuming
Show Business this is like living
in Silicone Valley where I I just you
know I imagine the people that work in
there was like oh my God if one more
person comes out to me talking
about their app I'm going to
blow my brains out um like out
here I don't know and this it's also
like the how the weather doesn't change
it just becomes like Groundhog Day and
if you're failing out here like how
mentally strong you have to be it's just
it's brutal so um H the
day job yeah well I would and I would
say what they're doing out here is is
yeah it's
it's uh I would say uh I can't get my
mind around that level of greed but I
think it's in all aspect it's it's the
corporate mentality it's that disease of
every quarter we have to make more money
how can we make more money money is you
have to take more cuz after a while you
can only charge so much for your product
and then what you have to do is you have
to start taking from people that create
the product and then I don't I don't it
just keeps going and then you just at
some point where can we look for more
savings just what we are we're at right
now it's like bone on bone and I don't
think you know what writers and
performers are asking for is like
they're not asking for the pie in the
sky they're just asking like can you
guys just be
satisfied with being multi multi
Millionaires and billionaires or
whatever and uh I'm lucky enough that
um I always stuck with my standup and I
always I always
knew I was like I can't get because I
used to see people you know get some
inroads in Hollywood and then they would
quit doing standup and I would be like
like dude you can't give up that level
of control these guys will turn on you
in a second and then all of a sudden
you're not making how Comics got their
feelings hurt with failed sitcoms or
what have you and they leave town if
their feelings hurt they don't
understand what they were dealing with
and then this is the thing and then the
hardest thing ever now you got to go
back on the road and try to make it
again in your 50s I mean I mean it's
hard enough to do it when you're young
so um I always knew that's why I I've
always been like I got my podcast and I
got my road and then I I just look at
Hollywood like whatever these
guys give me you know if it's cool I'll
do it but I'm making enough money doing
this that I don't I don't need right you
have Fu uh money kind of thing I mean I
don't I'm like anybody else like I'm
doing all right but like if I if I stand
still you know what I mean what was that
book they used to have us read where
that guy went all the way out to the
ocean with the big fish and as he was
coming it back in all the fish were
taking bites out of it by the time he
got back was it called the K what was
Aaron you read right do you remember
that book did they have you read that
out in the midwest there with an Heiser
Bush and all of that um I can't
remember the name of the old man in the
sea okay old man in the sea oh I'm
reading his short stories now that
turning Hemingway right that's right
yeah so that he he hooks his fish and
he's in this little fishing boat he
takes him all the way out to the Sea and
he risks his life to get this
fish and by the time he gets it all the
way back in the Sharks and all these
fish and he has like like
nothing left so uh I kind of feel like
the way they have the game set up and
the taxes out here it's like all
right I could stop working but not for
the rest of my life so that's something
I talk you got to lower your overhead
there's a nice mobile home park in uh I
know yeah yeah yeah go go live in a shoe
box maybe if you didn't have so many
needs like having a different room to be
in instead of sitting on top with your
whole family yeah you're in the
kitchen you're in the living room and
you're in the den and it's only a couple
of steps I do know
that that the what the crazy thing is
them trying to break unions the amount
of people that died so unions could
could exist and that I feel that's what
created the middle class I'm probably
wrong but I feel like because it
actually protected the worker and I just
don't know like it's such a great
country when people can get a job
manufacturing something and afford a
wife and kids and like for most people
they're smart
enough um that that's enough for him
like I wish that that was enough for me
like I didn't have to go out and go
you know get on a stage you like
me you like me you like me you know that
dumb you know um like I that's what
you know we go through some I see people
in these beautiful small towns I always
look at them going like that would have
been me if all this up
didn't happen to me and created that
void and I always look at
him like uh like uh with with I'm happy
for him and I look at him with like Envy
like I'm just like you know you I know
they got that little restaurant they go
to and they they go home they
got this
nice like you know a few of my siblings
live like that and I'm like I'm like
dude you got it all you got a house you
know beautiful wife you got you got it
all you got it all you don't want to
be you know remove all your
laptops and your liquids out of
your going to some goddamn place um and
I think to the level of travel we do is
not healthy mentally like it with
you like you know when you come off the
road you got to kind of be like
just want to be alone for a couple of
days and try to like slow the the
vibration down which is why I
want to read this book uh it's uh it's
it's it's a fun book it's great it's
it's you wait till you read
it it's just the no I like it's it's
the it's how people treat people with
unchecked power 100% 100% that's why I
never believed into the like you know
white people evil it's like no we're not
we have unchecked power and no group
should have that cuz when they do when
the sociopaths you know as as the
flowers growing the sociopath's head
comes the
first yeah and that's the dude that runs
it like people it's not going to be
good you know for anybody why is it
getting this deep you have a great
special so I got to put I got to put
asses I got to put asses in the seats
that's it all right well you got to get
some YY Road
I got to put asses in the seats well we
got to go out well this the thing you
got to go out that's what Paulie Shaw
tells me you got to go out you got to
get to the Midwest you got to go go go
yeah you got to go out there and you got
to you got to hack your own
Trail to build a through this
that's what you got to do you can't
you can't you can go out and open for
somebody but after a while you have to
leave
no's not going to be opening for anybody
why not nobody's going to want opening
for
I would do
it well you're you're you're a great
comic you can you can do it you know no
and I also enjoy great comedy and I was
also enjoy people being like who in the
is this guy we supposed to push
buttons right we don't want everybody to
come in and leave the same way we want
to affect people cuz we like to affect
people why now let me ask this why do
you why do you why do you think you do
that why do you
think because I don't think I've ever
seen you going on
stage with this I want you to like me no
no because I like I said I have this uh
I think what's held me back so long you
know to think oh I can do comedy and I
can be the funniest person that's that's
a that's a segment of ego and we grew up
with George Colin and uh I I remember
the first time I saw a comedy it was on
HBO On Location do you remember it
Freddy Prince and uh there was a little
brick wall and that was the first thing
but I never thought I was going to do it
but I've always uh respected it so I
never you know uh you know it's it's all
about your how you feel about to do
something you know like you you you you
quit your day job you said this is what
I'm going to do but I was always uh you
know trying to get better you know
intimidating you know it's intimidating
you know I quit my day job because I was
moving from Massachusetts to New York
but I had full intention of getting
another day job but what happened was I
had saved up money cuz I was living at
home with my parents I paid off my
credit cards I paid down my student
loans cuz I was just like I was so
afraid of moving to New York and like
not having any money and what the
was I going to do so I you know saved up
a couple of grand and I moved down there
and just ate you know I remember
I just yeah eat spaghetti every
night you know cheap and then and I
was thinking I got to get a day job I
got to get a day job and I looked couple
places and then it just sort of changed
to I need to get more gigs I need to get
more gigs and um and that's how it
developed yeah and
uh I do remember thinking like like that
was one of
the highlights of my career when all of
a sudden I didn't have a day job and
then it was funny cuz he was like I'm
have the whole day to myself and
then all I got to do is just go down to
the Sellar or whatever the comic strip
and do 15 minutes
make 20 bucks or eight bucks whatever
the they paid right and I got my
weekend gigs and I'll be good but then
you didn't realize that now you would
become this small business so right
you'd wake up and then it's like I got
to go to the gym I got to stay in shape
I got to I got to try to get an agent I
got to try to get a manager and then
when you get them then you have to work
them try to tell them what you want to
steer them to ask the and it just
became you know and now you got to have
a you got to have a website you
got to have these you got to put these
cards out and all all all the whole
different ways of promoting yourself
over the years that everyone was
trying to do and then Dane gets on
MySpace oh God you got to get on
Myspace and then it just all of that
um it just yeah it's never ending it's
never ending so yeah it's it's it's I
just thought I was going to be
laying around all day I was like it's
going to be
great no you don't all hell yeah and you
sit around just thinking about like what
if it all goes away and oh I pissed
off that club
owner remember Jamie Mada man he
threw me out of the Laugh
Factory what happened B you g on stage
and you all over the
place man I thought he was just joking
around thought he was joking around then
the next week I didn't get any spots and
I was like La man if you lose a club
you're then I made the mistake of
apologizing to him and then he knew he
had me under his thumb and then that was
my that was finished I had to go
back to I had to go back to New York was
that uh 98 or 99 I still remember that
you all over the place
man yeah he told me he told me this he
said uh you need a beginning and a
middle and an
end the audience doesn't know what the
beginning in the middle and end is as
long as they're laugh J has Jamie has
driven more comedians out of the
business and on the path he's a
necessary evil I love him but like yeah
you're right you're right
he either makes you go like you know
what is this what show business is I'm
getting the out of here or you're
like you know what this guy I'm
going a different way so I was like
this guy I sat out in front of his
Club 8:45 in the morning for a
600 p.m. setup uh sign up Tuesday to do
three minutes and I was the fourth guy
in line dude sunburn I went on
stage looking like a lobster
right I went up there killed I don't
know cuz I had such a little amount of
material like I could never never do
three minutes now and kill I would bomb
but back then I only had like whatever
you know so I did my best three minutes
I went up and I killed and I was like oh
man this is it man he's going to want to
manage me or anything and I went up
there and he just
I've told this story before he's
just like you're very
funny he goes you should talk more about
your father I go yeah you know I got
more bits about my dad and stuff I just
you know I only gave me you know I talk
about my mother he goes he goes your
father then he goes
how does it make you
feel when your father yells and then he
sat back and went like this you know
like he had the answer to all my comedy
problems and he was going to present it
in riddle form and I was literally I've
told the story I told this on Dom's ir's
when Jamie was there I was literally
holding on to the back of the legs of
the chair like nodding like I like I
thought he was fascinating I was like
this guy is out of his mind and
I I remember just sitting there nodding
I was like but I was really thinking I
was like I'm moving to New York I'm
moving to New York I'm out of I'm not
dealing with this guy and then what was
funny was I moved to New York and then I
got an acting gig out here and then he
was giving me spots and then the acting
gig went away and then he was he
he right your acting gig goes away and
then you all over the
place man and then he go he always goes
I never said that man I never said that
it's like you 100% said that you said
all of that I remember it because
it was a there was are big moments in my
career so anyway I'm talking too
much here cancel # cancel hman yeah so
well I appreciate you coming on give me
the book and the Boo and everything are
you sure you sure you don't want this so
you can remember I will I was there that
day my brother Bruce was there I was
living in New York and I was on the
Upper East Side and you never would have
known that that was happening it was an
absolutely beautiful day and I remember
it was so up was walking outside
and seeing people like eating brunch it
seemed so disrespectful to me
you know you go to a deli you get a
bacon get a bacon e egg and cheese and
go back
yeah they're like oh my God like I I
don't everybody was just literally one
of the best neighborhoods in the whole
wide world in in in oh yeah anything you
want there anything you want what's
funny though is after a while all of
Manhattan became the Upper East Side
like nobody could afford it
right I remember this douche a long time
AG to go to Brooklyn now I I lived on
the Upper East Side but it was I was way
up I was on like 97th Street and I
remember this guy goes oh yeah he goes
what building and I didn't realize that
he was being a snoody because if
you lived in a doorman building it had a
name right you know like the vampire or
the the extortionist and it had
amenities and all of that type of
he guys he's like where do you live I
was like uh the 147 East 97 Street
complex where there was like yeah that
was like uh whatever so anyway um it's a
thrill to have you on here dude and uh
than thanks for having me I hold you up
there with all the greatest Comics I've
ever seen dude you are literally that
good and I hope
someday enough people
watchh over the rainbow watch # cancel
Holzman he'll put asses in the
seat and you realize that I
suck yeah dude no one thinks they're
funnier than you dude you're you're
amazing so thank you so much #
cancel Brian # cancel Holzman check it
out and go see this guy at the
comedy Mothership Joe Rogan's amazing
new club in Austin Texas get out of the
humidity get in the club all right thank
you fantastic dude thank you so much
[Music]
for hey what's going on it's Bill bur
and it's the Monday Morning podcast uh
for Monday September 14th 2015 what's
going on how are
you um I know what you guys are
expecting they're probably expecting me
to uh talk about the Patriots
winning and the Steelers crying about
the uh the headsets or whatever the hell
they were crying about this week why get
why does everybody you know I love about
Giants fans they never about the
Patriots they just beat us all the rest
of you sit there crying every
week anyways uh I'm not going to get
into that um I have a very special guest
here one of my favorite alltime
comedians of all time but first I have
to read his amazing uh intro here um
Brian rean everybody is going to be
performing live at Radio City Music Hall
and the first time ever in the history
of Comedy Central Brian you might as
well talk at this point I've already
said yes um how many how many uh
specials would you guess that Comedy
Central has in their Mountain W I
probably quite a few but uh 7even 8
million yeah 7 to 8 million I think is
uh well this one I'm going to bet on the
over I'm going to say it's 9 million 9
million I like that uh 9 million
specials this is the first guy who's
ever had the nerve to uh tape a standup
special live on uh Comedy Central and
he's going to be doing it see if I can
on September 26 at 9pm. live from one of
the most legendary venues of all time
Radio City Music Hall
um I mean I'm looking the whole press
release you got like you know five stars
from Jerry Seinfeld Chris Rock Dennis
Miller Joe Rogan Patton Oswalt the the
Mark Maron The Who's Who and uh we all
love you man you are you are you've been
what's it like to have been a comic's
comic for a quarter of a century I it's
a huge huge honor man you know when uh
you know making audiences laugh is great
makes you feel feel good but to also you
know make the comedians feel like you're
doing the right thing that makes you
feel even better I know my fun in this
podcast is going to be torturing you you
with comp compliments cuz I can tell
that was the most uncomfortable I've
ever seen you hey what's it like to be a
legend Brian talk about being a legend
like God say I'll go I'll go right into
a bombing story let me tell you how
about when I bombed and that wasn't so
legendary no man I've been doing this
for 23 years I'm old now I am an
old man now I I know that every time
when I try to do stand up out in Silver
Lake I'm not saying the kids are bad
it's just I definitely feel like wow man
I feel like that that generation gap but
you you've been like since I
started um for those people like
unfamiliar who've been living under a
stand-up comedy Rock like like Brian
basically goes out and for 90 straight
minutes it sounds like a jet is landing
how hard this guy kills and he never you
and like me you couldn't be the more
polar opposite of me you don't you I
don't even think you say heck no sure I
do you say that okay but still I I know
I I do some hex and some dams but dude
your act is like airtight like nobody
can M no one can be like oh you know
he's just uh he's just what he's just
writing perfect jokes for I'm sorry
Brian I hate to torture you with this
but there's no other way to go with this
you're just you're an absolute Master
you're very kind very incredibly kind
and I cannot thank you enough very no
eye contact no eye
contact yeah I remember I'm going to
keep going here I remember when I when I
first started headlining uh in the late
'90s um The Legend back then was when
you booked Brian rean you would do two
shows in one night and you would do two
completely hour plus totally clean
absolutely destroying sets like you had
like the a set and the B set you had
like there was always this this Urban
myth he's got two notebooks they both
filled up one's one's the first show and
one's the second show he's doing he
literally the guy's got 2 hours and 40
minutes of a level material I I called
it the idiot and the odity oh those were
the two the two shows they were two
different 1hour shows and I would go to
a comedy club for like a month and um
and I would alternate them and the idea
was if somebody came out and they liked
what they saw they go wow he's got
another one maybe we'll come back and
see the other show as well so now did
that come about cuz back then when you
were coming up like you had to be like
anointed to do a special when nowadays
you just need somebody with the camera
and you you can put it up however you
wanted like back in the day HBO had to
say like you know what you're one of the
six people that were picking this year
or I didn't even think Comedy Central
was really making too many specials uh
back then so I was just wondering did
you like you wrote a special at that
point did you just say to hell with I'll
just keep writing like how did you end
up with that much material at one time
actually well just because I you know
I'm I'm always trying to write stuff but
it came about because do you remember
when people were starting to do the
onean
shows like Rob Becker defending the
caveman you know they would take a
standup and then kind of make it into a
little story with a beginning middle and
an end and take out a few laughs you sit
down behind a desk yeah I mean Rob
Beckers is great you but there were a
lot that were just you seemed like kind
of repackage stand up you know and
people were telling me well you should
do a oneman show you should do a oneman
show and I'm like I like standup I like
the way standup works I don't want
to I don't want to like you know do a
joke and then have a serious point and
then walk across the stage and have a
tear come out of my ey sort of dramatic
lighting yeah right you know what's so
funny I totally relate to that because
I've had so many people where like my
dream was always I just want if I could
sell out improvs that was the dream if I
could if I could just go like I to me
when I was starting out when somebody
said oh I have a gig in Houston this
week or I'm in Minneapolis this week
like to me there was nothing cooler than
that like this guy gets to get on a
plane and fly and people know who he is
and he gets to go in there and back then
was you get to wear the sport coat right
you get to go out and be be a comedian I
just thought that that was the coolest
thing ever and I don't know how you feel
about this but when whenever
um you could have like the greatest
special ever and then they're always
just like uh any TV any moov like for
it's it's always looked at um it's got
this weird thing where standup is really
respected by people but then it's also
looked at as just like this stepping
stone right into uh you know doing like
a a I don't know like a sitcom or being
some sort of actor or something like
that and I always just I always thought
like no dude this is the thing this is
the thing it always will be the thing I
can't get get fired from this I'm always
going to be employed and it happens in
real time there's no cut let's go back
and do it again and you're sitting in a
trailer for 14 hours yeah it it's you
know there are you know a few people who
like it as an end result I don't say a
few there are a lot of people who love
standup comedy but yes for a lot of
people it's a a stepping stone to get
into acting to get into a TV show or
movies and that's great um but I like it
as it is you know and um you know people
do always ask about the thing you don't
have you know um I just remember for
years you know people coming up to me uh
you know have you ever done The Tonight
Show or whatever and when I hadn't and
yeah like no no I haven't done that you
know you should call Jay yeah that's I
say yeah yeah yeah no the the very the
first year I was working at the comics
trip in Fort Lauderdale that I I was a I
worked in the kitchen you know I would
like cook burgers they would let me go
on stage at the end of the night and a
guy came up to me after a show and said
um Rodney Dangerfield is playing down
the road at the Sunrise musical theater
he goes why don't you go down there and
open for him instead of
this you know like like like all it took
is me to just know where the theater was
like I just walked down there oh is he
in town I where where is it that way so
I just go down there and I open for him
in a theater you just show with your
apron you're such a I'm working in
a kitchen here in a comedy club I could
go right down the road and open for
Rodney Dangerfield thanks for the
suggestion but you know what's funny in
a way that mentality is how I got into
this business was because I wanted to be
a comedian I didn't dare say it out loud
but I I I didn't think it was possible
cuz like when I was thinking about doing
it was which is like the late ' 80s
started in the early 90s but the late '
80s I first started thinking about it
but there wasn't any YouTube there was
none of that crap so to me I was living
in Massachusetts Show Business bus was
3,000 Mi away like it just seemed
impossible and then I was working in a
warehouse with this guy and he was just
going like dude one of these nights and
he like stand up like where goes one of
these nights I'm going to take a shot at
Jack Daniels and I'm just going to go
down to an open mic down the street and
you know and just go up on stage and all
of a sudden I was just like oh wow you
can just do that I thought I had to like
you know get my teeth capped and moved
off to LA and get a fake tan like I had
no idea how to so I always I always have
like a panic attack when I think about
that I going thank God I worked with
that guy and thank God that he said that
and he took it out of seeming like you
know it was like the Milky Way away he
he he like made it like yeah yeah just
go right down the street you just did
they did that guy ever do it you know I
don't know because we work together s
for such a short period of time I have
no idea that's the only reason why I
don't like telling that story cuz then
people like did that guy end up doing it
whatever happened to him he's probably
like some zillionaire Banker you know
I'm sure you know s pool loving his wife
and kids and his dog just totally happy
but it's just immed he didn't do what
you did in life so he must not be happy
when I when I first decided I wanted to
be a standup the only comedy clubs were
in Los Angeles and New York I was in
college in tiffan Ohio and I knew I
wanted to do standup this was before
what year what year was this uh 1980
this is going way back man and um so I
knew I wanted to do it but comedy had
not yet you know exploded it was only in
those two cities so I was gearing up to
having to move to New York City I'm like
I didn't know what was going on so what
I thought I had to do in ' 92 you
actually had to do in 80 that's what yes
and then I went back down to South
Florida which is where I grew up and I
open up the Miami Herald and there's an
ad in the Miami Herald for grand opening
for the comic strip comedy club in Fort
Lauderdale it says sister Club
of the famous comedy club in New York
City open mic night Monday
night and I'm like damn like like it
could not have been more beautifully
perfect like I don't have to move right
I don't have to move to New York City I
can just fill up the car with gas and go
up to Fort Lauderdale and try it and so
it became so much more attainable when I
saw that ad you know and that's where I
started that's amazing I very similar
thing I had I made a New Year's
resolution in 1992 that at some point in
the calendar year of 1992 I was going to
do an open mic that's how like shut down
and shy I was I was so nervous about it
and the second I said that within two
weeks uh in the school paper the
emersonian I went to Emerson College it
said uh Nicks comedy stop I had a
contest it was an ad find Boston's
funniest college student wow and the
whole thing was just uh just to pack the
club with a bunch of drunk kids buying
drinks watching their friends bomb so I
immediate I I I bought the paper uh
might even been free I think I can't
even remember it's a school paper I
think it was free and then I brought it
home and I just immediately called the
phone number before I chickened out and
I was just
like I want to do an open m and I
remember so many kids from Emerson
signed up that they actually gave us two
nights so I was supposed to go on at the
end of some the last Monday in February
and then they called up they said they
had overflow would you want to do the
first Monday in March and I was like
okay like just to put it off and then I
hung up and I felt like I pussied out
and um but very like a similar thing so
yeah I mean it's weird how things will
leap out at you I mean that you know all
the ad of all the ads in the world you
know for fast food places and hotels and
that ad for that comedy club like jumped
off the page to me it was like holy
man um it was just it was just perfect
and then I went there so it's 1980 so
you went down there so tell me about
your first when you went on stage uh
well actually they want they wanted you
to get there early to draw numbers so I
had to make the hour drive I was still
living with my parents in Miami I make
the hour drive up there and I get there
I don't know six and did they know you
were going to try it your parents I
don't know if I I may have told my
parents but I I didn't tell anybody me
too I didn't tell I don't tell nobody
nothing you know what I mean that was
like a mob hit yeah it's like I want to
go up there and if I bomb nobody's going
to know about this till the day I die
Brian you seem so quiet what's wrong
yeah well no I just did nothing you
know what are you doing this year I'm
just getting little dressed up and
leaving the house so I go up there and
there were like 20 comedians that had to
draw numbers you had to draw numbers
numbers for your time slot I I didn't
know what any of this meant and um I
drew I guess a good number you know I
had like a sweet spot right in the
middle and then right after the um the
drawing all these other open micers who
had done it before I I guess it had been
open like a month you know came up and
said I'll trade you I'll trade you I'll
trade you my number for your number and
all I knew is whatever I was holding was
valuable and I wasn't Trading for
nothing you know you know I'm like they
want this so I'm I'm keeping it so I
went on um and what they they had three
co-headliners it was very weird and then
they stuck the open micers up in the
middle I went on right in the middle of
the show and uh I just completely
blanked out on stage just complete wipe
out blank could not remember anything
and when did you realize that walking
towards the stage or when you got up and
turned and faced them what happened was
I had every word memory memorized I had
Hi how are you written down which hand
you were going to wave with
everything I had Hi how are you written
down and
memorized I walk on stage and that's the
first time I realize how bright these
lights are like I'm like wigging out
that I can't see a
soul and then I I started to say Hi how
are you in the microphone and there was
feedback I was too close I went
Hi how are you you know oh no so I did
my first ad lib I said uh well I've
already learned one thing I don't know
how to work a microphone and it got a
laugh oh
nice and then my brain just shut off oh
cuz you didn't you know what because I
had memorized Hi how are you to the next
thing and when I had lived I didn't know
where I was supposed to go after that
and so they laughed at my ad lib you
know well I don't know how to work a
microphone they laughed and I'm standing
there going I don't know I could I
blanked out blank blanky blank how how
long before you I stood there for about
um 10 seconds which seemed like N9 years
it was like an eternity and uh I said
well you're not going to believe this
folks but I forgot my act and they
laughed and I said no no no I'm I'm
serious and they
laughed it was like a Twilight Zone
thing like yeah but you learn in honesty
works and I and I started ad libing
about how stupid I was for not being
able to remember my ACT I went uh this
is great I spent all this time and
effort trying to figure out something
and I can't remember nothing you know
just off the top of my head and I
started killing and I and I I started
killing rolling about how stupid I was
um were you able to enjoy killing or you
so I enjoyed it I I I knew enough to go
well all I want is laughs you know what
I mean um and I'm just winging it you
know talking about what an idiot I am
and how this drive I made and all this
stuff memorized and I can't remember a
single thing blah blah blah blah and I
crushed you know at least in my mind for
an open mic dude that's crushing and
then I said well I can't see myself ever
remembering any of it so good night and
then I got this big hand I I walked
great I walked off stage and
then like the the headliners one of them
came up to me and said that that was a
great routine about how you pretended to
blank out I said I didn't pretend they
said that you really were winging that
and I was like yeah but I was like in a
fog you know what did he say you should
definitely come back was he a supportive
guy yeah I forget who it was but he was
supportive he said it was really funny
and um you know so what was great for me
is that my next time I went I remembered
my act and just ate
it that's hilarious but I had the memory
of knowing how to make people laugh from
the first time that just kept fueling me
to just keep going back and trying what
do you think would have happened if you
just did your wck and that first thing
didn't happen you completely ate it did
you have it you think you had an in you
to keep coming back I don't know you
know I've talked to other comedians
about this and and I
uh what's weird to me is that most
comedians I talk to say that their ver
very first time on stage they did well
you know and then didn't do well the
second time or third time and I wonder
how many potentially good comedians out
there it didn't go well and just said
hell with it now they're working at a
Home Depot just crushing it every day
right this the funni guy I've ever met
in my life and they just you know and I
I truly wonder how many people just had
the bad experience and go I I need this
like I need a hole in the head you know
so I know because the first time first I
my my first two were uh I did ncks the
the the talent thing it went okay and
then I did stitches
comedy club uh and went did okay and
those are both comedy clubs but the
first time I did a room that wasn't a
comedy club I've told this story a
zillion times in the podcast but it was
uh Jack Lynch had this room uh Kelly
something or other and it was some bar
and I went up and I and I absolutely
just ate it wire to wire I said on the
microphone Jack I'm bailing I said that
to the host and all the comedians went
ah like they
collectively were like disappointed in
me that I quit and I hated myself and I
remember uh but I would say it never
dawned on me to quit maybe it was
because I I did well those first two
times but I I just never I was just like
all right what can I do to avoid that
right that awful feeling again but you
know what's funny when I finally started
getting a little bit funny I actually
was doing one of your mannerisms and
people kept giving me going you
stealing from Brian look like I'm 2
three years in I'm going like no I'm not
you're a little your Crouch thing that
you do I was so influenced by you cuzz I
I I had seen you like first of all
everybody was freaking out when you were
coming to play Nick's comedy stop and
everyone's going dude Brian Ran's coming
you ever heard of Brian Regan and um and
I was like yeah I'd seen him a couple
I'd seen you a couple times on TV it's
like you got to see this guy and it's
like every comic in Boston was going you
got to see this guy and I was like I'm
doing a dick dory's room I like I don't
give a finish your set and drive in
here and I came in and I caught your
second set I still remember you wearing
this red button-down shirt you went on
stage and you you were killing so hard
like uh you know people wiping tears
away like falling into the a aisles and
stuff and it was just so like you
probably the first big comic like
traveling comic you came in you followed
all the Boston Heavy Hitters cuz you
know how they used to love sticking like
you know some legendary headliner with
all the local references in them feature
act to try and bury you and then you
went up totally clean and it was a
combination of watching you murdering
and then seeing all the comics that I
respected like turning into like
audience members and and they were doing
that laugh like like loving standup and
then being like why didn't I think
of that that's when you were doing like
the prescription lens uh windshield
thing and all that it was just it was an
amazing thing and I and I I appreciate
it and I was so influenced by that that
I started doing I acted out I was doing
I was doing like a little bit when I
would going to a punch line I would like
drop down a little bit and um it took me
I did that for about maybe eight months
to a year I was doing that and it took
me about seven years to get that stink
off of me people n he's stealing from
rean he's stealing from rean I was just
like I I was like I was two years in I
didn't know what I was doing well we're
we got to learn from something we got to
watch it but that's just a huge honor
and thank you very much I was actually I
was doing you a little bit and uh and
then I I they fortunately I had guys
like uh you know Voss and Norton and
Patrice and all of them they teased me
out of it we used to all we used to all
sit there and trash each other going you
know who you're doing and who you're
doing and uh I used to tell Patrice he
was doing a little bit of Fred sford
when he was going like yeah kind of kind
of do like that thing with his
[Music]
face um so anyways uh well thank you man
I I don't want to let I very much
appreciate the good words yeah well look
I I won't I won't tort you any more
compliments but so how did you come up
with the idea to to do a special live I
mean that's uh well you know um you were
saying about Comedy Central does a lot
of specials with Comedians and I I've
done a couple of with them a couple with
them in the past and uh you know I just
I just wanted to do something different
you know you know what I love about it
is the thing I hate the most about doing
a special is afterwards when you have to
watch the footage and edit and look at
yourself and listen to yourself I've
always for the most part throughout all
the specials I've done the few that I've
done is I just whatever show felt better
I just go just take that show and
Whittle that down to whatever time they
need because I don't want to sit there
and look at both shows then it's twice I
don't I don't want to deal with
any I hate it I absolutely hate it and I
avoid it the way I do like a term paper
so back in the day so I was thinking
about how you're you're not going to
have to do that you're just going to go
out you're going to do it and it's done
and then another thing too is like the
only time Comics do a a special where
they only have one show is if they don't
have any budget you clearly you know at
this point you can afford to tape two
four six shows if you wanted to you're
only going you're going to do it all in
one um what is the game plan you got
going into that as far as like is there
is there any like mindset that you're
going into before that like all right
Brian just go out there have a good time
and uh something shits to bed you
address it and keep plowing forward I
mean what are you going to do it it it's
weird like I don't want to over think it
you know what I mean like I on the one
hand I just you know I want it to be a a
show just like any other show there just
happens to be some cameras in there and
some people out there in TV World
watching it you know um but at the same
time I I want to have a couple of things
going on like I've been talking to my
manager it's like all it takes is one
idiot one idiot in the audience that you
know wants to uh you know have this be
his moment you know it's like you can't
watch
golf you can't watch golf without a guy
hit in a t- shot go in a hole yeah and
you just go jeez what are you really
that starved for attention you got to
yell that what are you going to go home
and listen to yourself that was me I
yelled go in the hole get in the hole
get in the they say yeah and they all
say it too it's like you can't even come
up with something original it's just you
know so I have this little fear not a
big one cuz my my my audiences are
pretty damn cool you know but all it
takes is one idiot in the audience who's
like oh wow it's going to be live I can
do something that you know you know I
can get some attention for myself so but
then you know something then if you
trash him then it just it what would
what that would actually do is it makes
it like really unique as far as like if
somebody were to do that and then you
were to trash him um even if they were
to kick him out like live on the thing I
don't want to talk about this too much
but you have a great crowd anyways to
give anybody any ideas but
um actually the way you're looking at
that you know when I I was trying to
think you know it's not like whenever I
go do a
show I I just do the show wire to wire
and I don't screw up any jokes you know
what I mean it's just when you're
recording it gets in your head like oh
my God right right the documentation of
that joke I flubbed this word and it's
just like you don't care when the
cameras aren't there so I would think
that you would just get into ah it
you know this is just I'm document my
performance of this hour on this night
and this is how it came out and then you
just go out there is that what you're
going to do yeah well it's been a while
since I've recorded an hour the last
thing I did was about 5 years ago and
that was um a CD mhm I get I get antsy
man when I get material I want to yeah I
guess you know a lot of people get
material and they go wow this is good
material I want I want to keep doing it
I get to where it's like I don't want to
do it anymore yes you know what I mean
it's like wow this is really good I'm
sick of it you know what I mean so I
want to I like to record it so it's
there you know I mean it exists but now
I can move on you know
that's one thing I'm really looking
forward to is this material that I've
been you know kicking around for the
last four five years and
uh I look forward to just nailing it
down and then being done with it the the
week after that it's probably going to
be more fun for me like just starting to
play around and and and get back into uh
some different stuff but I'm really
looking forward to it but as far as the
do you have jokes in your act right now
that you hate and you're actually
thinking like oh my not you hate but
you're just so sick of telling that
you're like I can't wait to record this
so I can just be with this I start
bumping up to that and I'm and I try to
resist it and fight it and then like as
soon as I start feeling that way I try
not to do that bit for a month or two
you know so that when I redo it it feels
fresh and this is a challenge because
I'm coming up on this special and I need
to have it in my bones to a degree but
not so into my bones where it's like
you're a machine up there you know I
mean you don't want to suck the funny
out of it you know so it's I always know
which ones subconscious I I don't even
realize how much I hate certain jokes by
the end of them um is when I go on once
I do the special it's just naturally the
ones you it's like you don't even make
the choice the ones that you hate you
just never do them again and I always
think like wow man I must have really
hated that joke I must have really been
sick of doing that thing but uh you know
what's funny for to me is that it's just
like in your normal progression you know
you come up with a bit you know some new
thing and you're excited about it you
you know you have your Hit List Right of
uh uh here's something new I want to get
to here's something relatively new I
want to get to and I'll look over that
before I go on stage but I don't have a
list of the bits that I'm
dropping they just fall away oh good
they just fall you know there's
something like you say about your
subconscious that just goes I've had
enough of this one and it's just
gone and then you and then a year later
you think and go oh wow I used to do
this bit about such and such and I just
it just fell away you I never did it
again after my special we got to take a
real quick break here so I can do a
little bit of advertising here and uh I
almost did the radio thing I always
think to do that we're here with Brian
rigger like like people don't listen to
these things wire to wire so uh I'm
going do a little bit of you going
listen to me read out loud here
everybody and I will be back in a second
all right and we're back um so I I was
wanted to tell that story uh you know um
one of the coolest things it was the
first time like I really got to hang out
with you and and uh meet you I was
playing um I was playing The Comedy
Works in Denver right one of the great
alltime rooms and uh you were playing
like the the United Center or the Pepsi
Center or something in Denver this you
playing like with the Avalanche play or
some Red Rocks I think it was Red
Rocks yeah where you too shot that video
yeah like a unbelievable 8,000 Cedar and
after you did your show you still took
the time to come in and catch my Late
Show at that point I don't think IID
really for I'd met you a couple of times
but I never really got to hang out with
you right before I went on someone goes
hey just so you know you know Brian
Regan's hanging in the back he came in
and wanted to check out your set and it
was the most ridiculous honor I couldn't
believe it then I was thinking like
don't go down in that Crouch
like he did back in 1995 he's like this
dud this guy's stealing from me
he's doing me with with filthy work they
going you too you to hey wait a second
no I'd be like you you my
filthy
ass um and then we ended up hanging out
and you were so complimentary and nice
and uh and also something that I loved
was you were like me you were over 40
but hadn't quit drinking I can't stand
people that just can't you can't
handle alcohol I mean right I should
talk right now I'm going like a I shut
it down every once in a while for like
70 75 days and uh uh By the time this
podcast comes out I'll be on like day 71
so uh well you know what was funny in
the middle in your set that night you
said that you weren't drinking you said
uh you know I don't I'm not drinking now
or something like that so I was thinking
a man we're not going to be able to have
a couple cocktails after the show and
then we went out to the bar afterwards
and I said you know I I I know you don't
drink and he go and you were like who
who hold on hold on buty boy yeah no I
was just like rean say if he's having a
drink I got to have a drink with rean
there's no way I'm not doing
this but I just take times off because I
find uh like one of the things that I
cherish about being a stand-up comedian
is the free time that I have
um to pursue whatever the I want to
do either just sitting on the couch like
right now you know it's a Saturday when
we're taping this and I'm taping three
college football games which I probably
won't watch until like Monday or Tuesday
and I just love that I can just have a
Tuesday that if I want to get up at nine
and have an English muffin and then just
watch three college football games in a
row like I'm some assistant coach
watching game film like I got to break
them down for somebody I just love that
I that I can do that but the the the
Dark Side of all of that free time is I
can go out and get hammered whenever I
want to and if I don't watch it I will
start drinking again like I did when I
graduated high school with I just
remember like 10 days after I graduated
high school my mother just walked in
classic her just really stoic and right
to the point was um your father and I
think you've done enough celebrating was
all she said and that was her way of
saying dude you're a Lush and
you're gonna end up in the gutter so um
celebrating yeah well I mean I was going
out to like like two three 4:00 in the
morning it was so funny cuz I I was
young I would go out I would be
absolutely hammered and by 8:30
in the morning I was at my warehouse job
unloading trucks and all I had to do was
make it to 10: when the Roach Coach came
and eat like a one of those sausages
right and then it just sort of leveled
me out and I was fine and somehow I
still had a flat stomach it was
I I didn't realize how lucky I was back
then so that's that's why I I just go
through periods of
uh just sort of shutting it down I I to
me it's like I it's a once
every two month thing you know like I I
I know the night that I'm going to be
able to get crazy and I'm careful and
I'm not driving and I don't I know I
don't have anything to do the next day I
mean like it's planned you know when
you're younger you know you just wing it
you know head go out but now it's like
it it's in my calendar I'm getting
wrecked on the
28th friend you know I was hoping you
going to say once every two months you
shut it down cuz you've been going too
hard like once every two months I drink
I'm like oh God I'm a mess I'm a mess
but I I got uh I don't know man like I I
go on the road with my buddies you know
any of those guys uh Jason lawhead Joe
bartnik uh just these great guys that I
go to the Rose Bowl with every year Paul
Bersy um they're part of that uh that
wave that came probably a couple waves
after my graduation class and they
they're all just guys guys cigar smokers
like to go to sporting events and all of
that so it becomes like uh sort of a
standup tour and a little bit of like a
bachelor party kind of vibe you know
minus of course the hookers and the blow
and all that type of we don't we
don't it's pretty mainstream it's all
above the board legal stuff but um and
what the funny thing is is we get to the
point like none of us you know will be
like dude we're not drinking tonight
we're not blah and just there's
something about the chemistry of all of
us really and the and the the free time
that we have that it we just end up
getting absolutely annihilated like some
of the worst nights of drinking we have
is like dude we'll go easy tonight right
we just shut it down you know we've been
hitting hard the last three nights of
tonight we do the show we get in bed we
hit the we hit the hotel gym and
then we're on the road sounds good yeah
yeah yeah and then all of a sudden like
you know lad's hosting he'll come off
and be like maybe I'll just have one
heater you know
and then it just and and then we're
laughing as we're doing it we're
laughing just laughing at ourselves so
it's like a game of chicken because I I
I have uh three different golf weekends
a year with brothers and friends and
it's just guy golf weekends and um I
don't even Golf and that sounds awesome
oh man we golf during the day we play
Texas Holdem at night and um and you
know I've got this bus you know that can
we use for the golf weekend and it's
kind of cool and sometimes we have a
long kind of cool that's awesome
it's cool play golf we get hammered
Texas Holding we got a tour bus it's
kind of cool I got a poker table that
was made to fit in the uh in the bus so
we can play Texas Holding while we're
rolling so anyway you know you get in
early you get on the bus early sometimes
7:00 a.m. you got a long haul to get to
the and there's like 12 guys and it's
like who's going to be the first one to
crack a beer you know and cuz
everybody's like and coffee and trying
to look like they're sane and normal you
know they have a thing of orange
juice we're all pretending like we're
normal yeah you know what I mean and
then one guy goes uh hand me a Budweiser
and then next thing you know 12
Budweisers are open and everybody just
goes yeah the first guy goes let me get
a budweis every just
oh yeah somebody's starting a little
early yeah right and then 5 minutes
later they're in you know oh the second
you just hear it open just like ah dude
I got to get one of those the last one I
last run I did I did with bartnik and uh
we actually had we actually went to the
hotel gym like every day this is when I
knew I was drinking too much and I had
to kind of shut it down I was getting
all bloaty and and uh we
had this thing that we did every day
though we after we worked out we came
out of the hotel we went onto the bus
and we had one bud light and we knew we
were just going to have one Bud Light
cuz we had a show and you know we're
older guys you know if you have two
drinks you're going to have to nap for 9
hours or you'd have to keep going and
you can go for like 12 hours or you
drink two and you're done so we would
have one and because I knew I was just
having the one I would like savor it
like I would just be like sipping it
like I was you know like when you stole
your dad's first beer and it was like
one of the highlights of the toys it was
a Bud Light I think I think I
could figure out how to make that in a
bathtub like a
Prohibition it was so cold and
delicious just sitting there and they
had you know the little TV there on the
bus and it just sat there we we would
always put on like sports center or
something and it was uh and then the
hardest thing is when you finished was
not in that next 10 minutes to grab the
next one I found out like if I just
could get through that 10 minutes and I
grabbed the water I started drinking
that like whatever that chemical need of
like yeah man let's have some more of
that I would kind of wear off and I was
able to do my show but uh it's something
that uh I don't I had my uh my brothers
and uh some other friends out in Las
Vegas where I live and uh they were on
their they were on a golf weekend I live
there and I was able to join them one
night and it was one of those nights
where I said you know I'm I got a car
for us you know and uh please call me on
one of these nights I'll fly in for that
oh man that would be fantastic
that's when you know in Aly call me in
for the
drinking when you're flying in oh yeah
to drink so um I don't play Texas holdom
I don't golf I'll just be that guy I'll
be the guy so you're not guilty I'll
just open that first beer yeah you'll be
our designated first beer of
so we go out and it was my you know it's
like all right I knew I could let loose
you know I didn't have my kids I didn't
have to drive blah blah blah blah so it
was one of those deals where you wake up
the next day and you're like I don't
quite remember the end of the evening I
swear I look on the I shouldn't be
telling the story cuz of but I I I see
nothing you're going to say is going to
be any worse than i' done the my shirt I
had a button-down shirt that I had worn
the previous night it's laying on the
floor next to me on the bed on the on
the floor next to the bed I pick it up
and there's a tire mark across the back
of it a car tire mark and I don't I
don't know how it got there I'm
like I mean a car couldn't have run me
over I mean I'm I'm alive I'm in bed I
think you went a little will faral I
think you took the it was literally a
tire mark and I had to call my brothers
and go how is a tire mark a car tire
mark on the back of my shirt and they
told me that we were getting in the car
and that my foot hit the curb and I kind
of like tripped and fell on my back
underneath the car and like I my back
ended up against the car tire they say
you don't remember that I was having to
pick you up and put you in a limo and
I'm like damn dude you fell under
underneath a car yeah not into a car not
on a car I fell under it you fell under
it without it moving it's all got sucked
under that's like a trick not even
possible yeah that's a trick shot coming
off a curb I don't know how you could do
that they said I did some weird kind of
flip around and then ended up with my
back up against a tire I'm like did did
you say I should go home after that I
hope those were your lines yeah it's
time for him to get home I uh Joe de R
Roa another one of my great Drinking
Buddies he's got one he's got a buddy of
his back home uh you know when you have
a beer in a shot which is one of of my
favorite ways to start out you know what
I mean just sort of set the tone and uh
his buddy calls it bingo bango oh yeah
which is the greatest thing ever to me
he just go he came showed up one time he
had a shot in a beard and Joe was just
going like hey what do you got going on
there he goes you know bingo bango he
just kind of went like with the shot
bingo bango you know hit this one then I
hit that one I would think Bango is the
uh would be the shot Bingo's got to be
the beer right well you do the shot
first and then the beer right shot and
the beer so I would say Bango bingo I
was uh look at me I'm trying to rewrite
it out on the road and uh this guy
ordered a bunch of um Irish car bombs
okay that's you drop it it's a big thick
black stout beer and a big glass it's
not a Guinness what is it it's yeah
maybe a Guin and then you take a shot of
whiskey and you dro the shot glass into
the beer so the whiskey and the beer are
all together and then you chug the whole
thing yeah all right Irish Car Bomb mhm
well I got the name wrong and then the
next time I was in that City all these
guys got it was Philadelphia and we all
went to this like kind of cool rough
Philadelphia Bar yeah and it was this
guy who we had done the Irish car bombs
with and his friends so I'm trying to be
like a guy and I thought it was a
Mudslide I thought that which is you
know chick
drink so I'm trying to fit in and I went
who wants to do some mud slide
and uh my buddy who was the one who did
the Irish car boms looking at me like
what the hell are you doing and I'm like
no and and now I don't want to back down
I'm like oh oh you guys don't want to do
mud slides huh like I keep pushing it
and they're all looking at me so I go
over to the bar you know Mr big uh big
bartender over here seven seven mud
slides set them up all of us
mudslides
so they said all these chick
drinks and then next thing I know we're
doing like these light
cream shots oh they all went with it
yeah well because they knew I was a
comedian and they were like well this is
something this guy likes I guess you
know they they didn't want to like
undercut me and then my friend finally
took me aside and go what the hell are
you doing here man and I went this what
we did last time he goes those are Irish
car bombs
man dude that's like a reoccurring thing
with you it's like you're one of the
smartest guys I no but you're always
saying I'm a and all that type of
thing you just always seem like have
these socially awkward do you know what
D roza did that when he was in Boston
hang hanging out with me we uh we did
the shows over at the uh The Wilbur and
afterwards all my my knucklehead
friends from high school all my great
friends um we were all
drinking and uh and one of my buddies
was really talking to D Roa like they
just sort of hit it off right and then
you know he and he walked over me one
point he goes dude he goes what's up
with you he goes what's up with your boy
I go I don't what do you want M he goes
he he goes I just asked you know what do
you want for a drink he he wanted a
White
Russian and he goes dude he goes dude
I'm all set with that guy so I'm
laughing thinking he's just breaking his
balls so later on in the night after we
go to leave and I'm laughing I go J Ro
you know what's hilarious when you
ordered that white russian my buddy was
breaking your ball balls to me saying he
goes dude I'm done with that guy and and
then Joe just goes is that why he
stopped talking to me he just he would
talked to me for the rest of the
night he was dead serious which killed
me cuz that's such like a Boston thing
where like like that's the like that
that alone I imagine Philly's the same
way if you were to order like the wrong
like someone's just I like this guy this
guy's cool and then all of a sudden you
order you order something that's just a
little too soft yeah over right
you're dead to me mudslides mud I should
get together with him we'll do some
mudslides and some White Russians man
white white russian Chasers
um All Right Bingo Bango Bango Bingo
little sugar Savory sugar salt or
something MH um all right let me uh let
me make sure that I I I promote this
thing I'm sure this went by and this yep
I knew it 44 minutes already uh before I
get out of here um I I do want to bring
this up you we have to talk about the
time when uh we decided for some reason
I'm I'm I'm going to say it was my idea
that we were going to do a show together
you know and this is of course was was I
was like not only is this guy the
funniest dude ever he also likes to
drink I have to do a weekend with this
guy but I knew that you were playing
like these giant places I think I was
doing clubs or whatever and so I was
like I'll open for you I don't give a
and then you were like hey why
don't we just do a club you know the
whole excuse was for us to drink so like
why don't we just we'll just do a club
we picked cobs comedy club in San
Francisco and it was just like you know
for charity for charity you so we
figured we won't even make any money
it'll just be an excuse for you and I to
hang to get together and drink and I was
I was going on first you were going
going on second and uh and and that's
how I I found out about the St Jude's
charity which I still donate money to
and uh it just seemed like such a great
idea in our heads it's she like yeah
it's you know I'm completely filthy
you're totally clean they're going to
get the they're going to get the total
standup white guy Spectrum here and we
went up there and I go on stage and your
crowd was looking at me like who is this
angry
leprechaun and I would say on a scale of
1 to 10 i' give my set was about a four
and then you go on stage I'm going all
right Regan's going to or at least re I
I felt bad I was like oh man I kind of
bombed in front of his crowd and
everything and then you you go on stage
I remember my sister was there you were
killing her and then all my
friends fans are sitting there looking
at you like he's been on stage for8
minutes he hasn't said you yeah I
don't I didn't feel like I killed either
I mean I I felt like like you say I I I
I you know I did fine but I think we
both did fine I don't like to do fine
you know what I mean fine is not what we
want but you know it was like for a good
cause but yeah I think it was like the
two desparate if that's the right word
you know audiences too big a gap yeah
and I remember afterwards sitting in the
bar and it was sort of like the elephant
in the room that we didn't want both
wanted to dress that we both just sort
of did find and we were just sort of
sitting there it was ruining our night
sitting there drinking and then finally
you brought it up you just like like
three bears you just like yeah so hey
what did you uh how' you feel about that
I was like I didn't think that went that
good and then we were sort of standing
there little buzz going like yeah dude
what the that was for charity like
we said we didn't have to be there we
almost got like pissed for a second that
we just started laughing and realized
that there was too big of a gap yeah
well it was a noble cause you know
what's weird about that too is uh I
think I forget what the charity ended up
being American Heart associ iation or
something like that or I thought we did
the St Jude thing I it was one of those
two but I remember Cancer Society
something but you know we contacted my
manager's office contacted them that we
were going to just donate all the money
and like they don't say yes right away
which is weird to me they're like well
who are these guys and I'm like that's
right you know and and they want to know
a little bit about us it's like wait a
second we're we're giving money we're
not asking you for money and it was like
you have to figure out how to give the
money away but uh you know what I think
that was cuz it was
probably the way things are nowadays
like if if if they get associated with
something somebody who controversial or
yeah whatever like say Donald Trump the
week he said you know I I guess
evidently all Mexicans are rapists he
was saying something to that effect and
uh if he was to donate them money like
the blowback could go on to them like
you're accepting money from a known
racist and like Hey we're trying to cure
cancer here right right you know so
anyway yeah know I'm Sor I probably
shouldn't have brought that up uh no it
was great man it was uh it was a blast
and I and I thought we had a great time
that night hanging out so uh it was cool
well I would like to have done a little
better I'm not going to lie to you you
know it still bugs
me I think I probably said that during
my said like dude you understand I don't
have to be here right now it's
like I'm working for free can you can
you give up a little bit we should do
like the opposite extreme like I should
perform in front of your crowd and then
I'll get a one out of 10 and you get a
10 out of 10 and then you could perform
in front of my
crowd and have maybe we need we need
somebody to feature to kind of sort of
bridge bridge the Two
Worlds yeah like a David
Feldman CU it's un unbelievable comedian
unbelievable joke writer but he will out
of nowhere say on stage
maybe I don't know are you a sports fan
Brian I like sports but I'm always
reluctant to say I'm a sports fan
because then I immediately get hit with
the question I can't answer I grew up in
Miami I'm a dolphins fan I like football
and I like golf you know what's the
great thing about uh you coming out of
Florida Florida has a bad reputation for
comedians like they try to say that a
bunch of hacks come out of there and uh
then you're always the go-to guy they're
like you they're like Brian rean
they'd always Nam three I forget who the
other two are but every city I think
kind of just has three good ones every
state at this point I mean how there's
only like the top 100 right comedians
you got 50 states you got two you got
two two from each state yeah who are the
two from Rhode
Island that's funny everybody's got that
oh I was trying to steer the
conversation towards Sports because I've
been defending my New England Patriots
as they've literally become like the
Antichrist uh the anti Christ however
however you're supposed to say it and
just now at this point like we just
after the 9 millionth thing that we've
been accused of of course just accused
nothing has ever been proven other than
that we cheated for one game in 2007
where we filmed the Jets and then a
bunch of people were like well then your
Super Bowl championship shouldn't count
it's like yeah they should because it
wasn't against the rules for us to be
doing what everybody else was
doing we just ignored them and we
cheated against the Jets and we got
ratted out by man Genie other
than that it's just been a bunch of
hear S I was just hoping uh you
would either 100% agree with me or 100%
disagree with me and we get into an epic
argument about it but you're you're into
golf do you watch Tennis at all did you
see Serena lost I saw that she lost yeah
that that was devastating to me I hate
that's why I hate watching tennis and
golf those are the two most
brutal it's all on you it's like doing
it's like it's like doing standup on a
late night talk show if you go out and
bomb it's not like you're out
there with somebody else it's just 100%
you right trying to keep your emotions
in check like the first time I actually
sat and I watched a a golf tournament
wire to wire I watched the Masters in I
think 2007 it was when the wheels came
off with with uh Kenny Perry Oh and I
was watching that whole thing rooting
for this guy and he's never won it he's
going to win his first major blah blah
blah the guy was like three
holes away the wheel and I I saw his
kids go from tears of joy to to
Devastation like the guy died and I
later heard that he when he lost he
didn't even talk to his family I'm sure
he said a couple of words he just got in
his car and just started
driving and I remember being as a sports
fan so upset that I I actually sat and
watched that happen to a fellow human
being I felt horrible I felt like I was
looking at a
an execution it's like you're watching
an execution almost you know
um but I mean there are similarities
between that and what we do you know
it's like uh you have a horrible set
somewhere especially on
TV you know but at least at least you
can blame the crowd on some level you
can stand you know not on TV but in like
a a comedy club oh you people you
can do something to to try to do
something to to at least some sort of I
better at that than I am man minor
victory in it did they just have to sit
there and and and as people are
commentating who don't nearly would
never have the will or the skill to do
what they're doing and just be sitting
there going oh the wheels are just
coming off right now you can see he's
he's just visibly upset he's perspiring
and they're just sitting there just just
giving play bypl Nobody you bomb is a
comic as bad as it gets there's nobody
giving play bypl doing that Mystery
Science Theater thing as you're doing it
that's all I'm saying so I I I like golf
I actually love tennis but just I I like
watching
somebody I went to the I was in France
this year and I went to the uh the
French Open finals and I was so excited
to see jokovic win the French and then
he would have won on all four all
surfaces and he would have become part
of this short list and he won the first
set and after he won it like he looked
over at his coach and he did
like that that Tiger Woods fist pump and
I was like oh man this guy's dialed in
he's dialed in he lost the next
three straight oh man and it was just it
was and it was great to see that war
rinka guy win his first one but that's
one thing
that is so great about sports is if you
do win a championship or you do win
something you have that Eureka moment
where you can jump up and down and
celebrate and hug people most jobs don't
have yeah no that Line in the Sand
moment you know where you can just
go yeah you know you go to work 9 to 5
and you do what you're supposed to do
you don't have some moment where you're
just jumping up and down on your desk
you know um that people they should do
that for people every Friday when it's
like 4:59 and they're like you know do
that one minute left in the period like
they used to do in the Boston Garden
that would be good a countdown yeah from
10 seven six
people people got the goggles on
spraying champagne and all that and
then you go home for the weekend like
all we did it you know we had a good
week at work that might actually be a
morale booster especially if like some
job I think that would be a
great idea yeah you have your week your
weekly countdown man you send everybody
home in a good mood absolutely well dude
we got to we got to I got to wrap this
thing up I got to do some more
advertising here but it's it's been an
absolute pleasure as as a fan of the art
of standup comedy to watch as much as
your career as I've seen and to actually
you know when you came down to The
Comedy Store Comedy Store The Comedy
Works that that is still and always will
be one of the biggest highlights of my
career and uh I will definitely be there
what what is the date of when you're uh
shooting it here I got uh September 26th
a Saturday um 9:00 um on Eastern time
and I don't know what time it'll be on
all the other time zones but uh 9:00
Eastern on Comedy Central Bill you're
the best man live standup special ever
first live special on Comedy Central I
think HBO has done one I think Seinfeld
did a live special on HBO but this is
comedy Central's first one so that's
it's incredible thank you it's
incredible Hey listen man I think you're
great I've always loved your comedy I've
always loved your perspective I love I
love your
cursing I love your drinking um no man
um and so I just wanted to return the
compliment man you're that's why we
wanted to come down to see you because
you're great well I appreciate that and
next time you are boozing I don't play
Texas holdom or golf I'll learn the
Texas holdom golf I can keep it on the
course hit me up dude I'll fly in I'll
fly in I'll tell my wife I'm doing a
corporate kick I just I just won't show
up with any money afterwards all right
please tune in September 26th at uh 9:00
p.m. on Comedy Central Eastern Time to
watch uh their first live standup comedy
special with with one of the greatest
comedians of all time Brian rean thank
you so much for coming on Brian thank
you Bill all right
what's up everybody and welcome back to
the anything better podcast and this is
the week two NFL Edition um before we
get started we have to obviously shout
out our great sponsor it's the
betmgm app guys um place your first bet
at betmgm Sportsbook wager through bmgm
Sportsbook mobile um application of at
least $10 guys $10 you will receive $200
instantly in additional winnings
regardless of the Wagers outcome I
believe the bonus code is B uh not bur2
200 B
rr200 all right how to get this offer
it's very easy four easy steps you
download the bmgm Sportsbook app uh on
your Android your iPhone okay uh visit
betmgm.com sign up deposit at least 10
bucks guys 10 bucks into your newly
created account place wager in the
amount of at least 10 at standard odds
price which is a qualifying bet once you
have placed a qualifying bet you'll
receive $200 guys $200 in bonus bets
regardless of the outcome of your wager
it's that simple use bonus code BB uh
200 guys also it's not too late for the
Survivor pool uh even if you missed week
one you can go back and uh you can sign
up for the Survivor pool and you can get
in go to the promotions tab on the bmgm
Sportsbook account and access Survivor
pool Challenge free to play create an
entry choose a team each week you know
how the Survivor Pool Works the team
just has to win and uh if if the team
keeps winning you go every week until
the end and you will get a prize so you
could still do that it's still available
uh now not for the
250,000 like it was but you could still
get prizes and join now so do all that
bonus code a bur 200 and uh get get at
least 10 bucks in and you get up to 200
in in your bets so there you go um what
could I say week one what could we say
Bill and I both went two and two it's a
tough it was a tough week you know me
and Bill had some good picks Bill hit
that Dolphins thing I hit the the Lions
thing in the you know the Giants you
also your Jags was the lock of the week
my Jags was the lock of the week and uh
I went to the Giants game Aaron Rogers
went down if he didn't go down you know
who knows but I also said I also said
the bills were going to win I like the
bills to win
um I went back the last second Paul the
whole time I was talking for a
month I was saying Aaron Rogers is going
to come down fourth quarter comeback how
awful is that how much fun did
all football fans lose because they
won't let him play on natural grass Paul
the fields getting the blame
now dude I gotta be honest both New York
teams the Giants go down on that first
drive looking great they get to the 15
yard line saquin is is doing his thing I
go oh my God look at us we're ready for
the NFC Championship we're going to go
prance right in and then a blocked field
goal for a touchdown and a beating to
the likes of which I haven't said I've
never seen a building know it was over
and have it be over that fast in a blink
of an eye it was my thing was
your Instagram stories Paul was gonna do
the he was gonna in you know do
the whole story about I'm at the game
you you didn't get past the
national anthem I did two started with
the national anthem the American flag
and then you were on ra radio
silence I was waiting for one thing to
cheer for and put on the Instagram story
and it never came uh the lack of traffic
at the end of the game maybe you could
have filmed that cruising through the
Lincoln
Tunnel dude that reminded me of that
KCU George Bulldogs game we went
to that leaky roof and both
everybody's like I was like everybody's
taking Georgia man they're getting all
these points let's take TCU they always
they always put up a good fight those
dude I gotta be honest
with you man that was such a bad loss
you know me I try to find the positive
and the Silver Lining but if your
offensive line is that bad week one
against the division rival at home dude
I just don't know like I that kid was
running for his life nowhere to go no
one to throw to the the Dallas Cowboys
were joking like Oprah did you see them
the Dallas Cowboys were joking like
Oprah on the thing and he just goes and
you get a a sack and you get a sack and
you get a because they sacked us that
many times they're literally on the side
that's a good joke to do with somebody
who's not in your Division I know I
would do that if you gotta play
him again that's that's uh unnecessarily
not to be the white guy here
because I did hear this guy on during
the Raiders game uh when uh was it
jakori Myers whatever jacobe Myers gets
a touchdown and then he gets like a
penalty for taunting he goes when you
make a big play you have to control your
emotions I mean what is that yeah that
doesn't even make sense when you hit the
lottery you got to sit on those emotions
you know that dback was talking to
him the whole way down and then
he beats him gets a touchdown he was
over him for two seconds and they throw
the flag yeah ah they've been doing it
all the way since back Jim McMahon no
fun
Le I don't know man and then they were
going we want them to quit by halftime
they're saying on the side hope listen
hopefully the Giants wake up and that's
it Aaron Rogers thing absolutely
brutal Jets still win and everybody in
New York and everybody in New York is
delusional bill now the Jets are gonna
still win the Super Bowl and the Giants
are done and it actually nobody's saying
that dude no one's saying the Jets are
gonna win the Superbowl no no they're
they're happy they're going oh the Jets
it's not over we got the the kid did
good it's like relax can we talk about
the tragedy of Aaron Rogers oh I
mean Jesus I don't think I've ever been
so amped up for that this guy
with all the experience going up against
the clamation kid there out there
with the Buffalo Bills you know
and just all over what did the Jets do
Paul they have cursed four plays
dude into his career four gone done over
ACL tear I mean Achilles tear
unbelievable man you think he's done you
think he's done for that I mean some
people saying career ending I mean some
people say that's an obvious career
Ender but what do you think he says no
he says I'll be back next year for the
opener I think he's going to try to
fight back but dude 39 years old
complete tear that Achilles is real
tough I mean I'll tell you what sucks is
HD TV like now somebody like
zoomed in saw the explosion inside his
cap it's like they told me it I get it
because people want to be like that's
definitely an Achilles that's that's
definitely you're not a
doctor yeah you're not a doctor that's
where the Achilles is you don't know
that it's definitely an Achilles you
have no idea how much slow
footage have you watched of Achilles
exploding exactly I want to know your
opinion on gambling week two of the NFL
Week one's a mystery what's going on
who's going to be what do you find week
two easier or harder than week
one I find week two just as hard I don't
think it's set in stone until three or
four to be honest I like I don't know
who the Giants are I don't know if
they're going to go in against the bad
Arizona team and do anything I don't
know if that offensive line just quit I
don't know so but I tell you what I do
know I do know what my first pick this
week's going to be and I tell you what I
tell you
what PA's feeling it give him the rock
uh this is a this is a the only reason
I'm taking this game is because it's
three points and it is actually a
difficult game but it's a game that has
to happen okay now let me tell you
something when Paul ver picks it you
want to know why I beat the book two
years in a row
[Laughter]
I'm gonna tell you why the reason why I
beat the book two years in a row is
because even if I lose the bet I take
the BET knowing I could sleep at night I
could sleep after it okay that's how I
do it I could
sleep knowing that the the Los Angeles
Chargers who lost week one listen to me
who lost week one okay have to win this
game Justin Herbert one of the only
quarterbacks that played good last week
they cannot go 0 and2 and I think
they're a better team than the Titans
are I'm going to take the
Chargers uh I guess are lay wait who's
Andrew by the way this is this is the
Titans are getting three
correct yeah Chargers are minus three
I'm gonna take the Chargers minus three
not going 0 and2 they should win that
game by a field goal at least I'm GNA
take Justin Herber and the Chargers
bouncing back in Tennessee
hard week of practice can't go 0 and two
that's my first
pick I like it all right I like to I
like the Chargers getting points I
thought they were laying I didn't like
that I like the I like that bet a lot
all right I'll tell you this right now
Paul week one is not your whole
season for some reason the Jets with
that amazing defense are getting nine
points in Dallas I think Dallas is out
there they're going to titty bars
they're sucking their own dicks a little
bit they're doing their Oprah
Impressions and all of that you know
they went up against the weak offensive
line having your boy from duke running
all around like he can't find his
calculus goddamn textbook there
I'm gonna take the Jets getting nine
points well I'm up nine nothing before
it even start who am
I little stuff pretzel I I love
that pick with that defense I love that
pick I do too and the Cowboys are the
Cowboys until they're not they
haven't done since uh
before Bill Clinton put his cigar not in
the humodor Paul not in the humodor
oh he put it in the human human door the
human door all right uh the human door I
love that pick I love that pick the Jets
get that defense oh my God you imagine
if she ever cut you off in traffic and
you were giving a shut the up
you human human
door you human door you human door uh
that's
great
um all
right it's a weird week man it's a weird
week but here we go am I gonna do it of
course I don't know Paul I never hear
Paul Paulie usually likes the weeks
Paulie brings the sunshine I don't know
this is this is a kind of a a top I
don't love this I don't love this week
sometime I see the lines usually and I'm
like oh I got my three or four I don't
like this week I think it's I think it's
it's weird um it's like seeing a pretty
girl fall and then she's drinking red
wine and she smiles at you and teeth are
gray he
ah all right well
look the Giants lost 40 to nothing at
home they got completely
embarrassed the entire city is
on the Giants everybody's talking about
the Jets I saw saquon's face during the
press conference and he
looked dude he looked you here's what
I'm going to say we're going against one
of the worst teams in the NFL dude we're
playing the Arizona Cardinals new coach
they're all over the place it's not a
good organization right now as much as
they were good to
us I gotta take the Giants week two
bouncing
back uh minus five and a half I think
the Giants should beat the Cardinal by
at least a touchdown and if not the
Giants Giants are lay in five and a half
you get Giants no Giants are laying five
and a half oh I that down on my card is
plus five and a half I'm like that's the
biggest gift I've ever seen and but out
of respect Paul that's how much I love
you out of respect I'm not jumping on
that I know Paul I know Paul's gonna
take the Giants I look if if the Giants
are gonna lose like that week one and
then go to Arizona and lose I gotta see
it I gotta see it so um it's like when
you got when it's like Andrew it's like
waiting for the Flop I got a I got a
decent two car I gotta see the Flop I
got to see them go I got to see them
lose to this team if it's going to
happen I don't think it's gonna I'm
going to take the Giants to win that
game game by a touchdown and have a big
bounceback week Giants minus five and a
half I going to tell you this right now
if the Giants lose that game outright
Paul I'm sending you a shuder re
board all right and a and a new
Nicks hat I'm gonna get you all set up
for
October because I don't like seeing a
sad Paul ver and if you guys you guys
get blown out and lose it I I don't know
um all right Paul I gotta tell you once
you took I had I did the Jets pick and I
had the Giants on my card even though I
had it the wrong way once you took that
all of a sudden it's starting to look
like slim pickets
here um great actor by the way slim
Pickins um
I I think I'm going to take this is a
weird one
Paul I'm gonna take the Colts getting
one that's a good one on the road
against the Texans I just feel like the
Colts are one of those weird ass teams
no the Colts aren't getting one though
the Texans are getting one
cols are L like
dyslexic did I read everything wrong the
Colts are laying one the team that's
second all right all that then are
the Pats getting three at home against
the Dolphins did I write that one down
right yeah the Pats are getting three at
home all right Dolphins coming off a big
win against the San Diego
Chargers all the analysts have
the Pats dead and buried put up a great
fight against the Eagles
um you know I'm gonna take uh I'm GNA
take the Pats getting
three bill bellich I think he's going to
frustrate them enough I like this new
Patriots offense even though I
didn't see a second of the game I I
didn't watch any highlights Paul just
from what I heard um we gotta win this
game and the fact that you guys were
kind of getting you know getting it
started getting it to you handed to you
by the Eagles and you guys came back and
M Jones had that you guys figured
something yeah I heard I heard there was
a little questionable call there with
the uh with the ball or
whatever the placing of the ball dude
you guys belich and the defense the
Patriots is a team you bet you just
can't bet against at home getting points
but the Dolphins man they have on
historically Paul I can tell you this
Paul here's a gift for you whoever wins
this game p Dolphins next time they bet
next time they play bet the opposite
they go one in one every
year D the Patriots are so scary when
bich retires I'm still not touching
it yeah I mean Paul let's let's be
honest the dance is over all right now
we're coming we're coming right now we
got
uh I'm trying to figure pick a celebrity
that has a sibling that won't be
insulting I gotta here's my pick here's
my pick I just it just hit me now it
just hit me
now the Detroit line lions are at home
after that unbelievable win in Kansas
City they are playing the
Seahawks they gotta win the game by five
or more I think they're flying I think
the Seahawks are due for a Bad season I
think the Gino Smith honeymoon of last
year is over I think Sneaky Pete is on
the
decline I think that the lions are
absolutely still going to just take off
this year and have a monster year and I
don't see the Seahawks stopping that
that crowd's going to be going nuts
after coming back from Kansas City and
they got a win by six or more five I'm
sorry I'm taking the Lions laying four
and a half points in Detroit this is
their season and I don't think the
Seahawks are the team that's going to
stop them the Lions go two and 0 and
they win this game by 10
points Jesus I look at that game the
exact opposite that's a trap game all
right that's I think that's a trap game
and I think uh I like Gino and and Pete
car P you know what P Carol's doing
right now he's laying off Detroit Pizza
he's a maniac he's chewing that
gum he's taking the stairs instead of
the escalator and I I don't I don't I
didn't like four and a was it four and a
half four and a half I like your
confidence though because I do like the
Lions um I'm worried I am worried about
that game all right Paul I'm going to go
the other way here I'm going to go the
other way I think the uh I like the
Eagles at home getting six and a half
versus the Vikings I don't think they're
gonna win the game but I think uh I
think they're strong enough and every
year everybody gets all amped up
about the Vikings they're gonna do this
Paul they're gonna do that and they
never do just just just I mean a lot of
this Paul is I'm going on his
history oh tonight tonight you mean
tonight's game game yeah Paul why don't
I get a win or a loss out of the
way all right Vikings are getting six
and a half huh Vikings are getting six
and a half yes Vikings are getting six
and a half dude what what the did I
do this week my whole card is
upside down I I don't know who shot are
the Chiefs getting three and a
half are the Jacks getting three
and a half the Jags are getting three
and a half it's always the home team
that's second that that the line applies
to whichever team is in bold print is
the line is
two no I thought the bold print me it
was there were a home team
it is their home and then that's the
line that appes to
them all right the Packers getting one
or laying
one uh they're laying one the Packers
are minus one laying
one I wrote everything down backwards
and I still thought it was a tough week
but I also Pi game I'm also picking
games plus one minus one S I got the
Jets I got know I got I got the Jets the
Colts and the Pats right look at me
going the old AFC East here
um the Vikings are getting six and a
half they don't do very well in Prime
Kurt Cousins doesn't do very well in
prime time and the Eagles right now I
mean their defense Thurday night I hate
Thursday night games I
everybody's all banged up and I'm
gonna take the gief the giefs the Chiefs
laying three and a half against the
Jags um they're a Super Bowl
team they got they know they that was a
pretty big lost last week uh as much as
I like Trevor Noah down there in Jaguar
which he's been doing on The Daily Show
and on Sundays I mean what is that kid
sleep Paul when does that kid sleep
Trevor Lawrence all right the the
what I call him last year Paul
the goodlooking zombie what was he oh
dude you said something it was great I
forget what he was there's something
about him dude if that guy's not AI I
don't know who is um yeah I'm going to
take the
Chiefs I mean come on dude it's it's
Pat Patrick Mahomes is Kelsey
coming
back I don't even need half the
information I need this week I don't I
think
kelse what he's expected to play sorry
yeah I think Kelsey's back all
right all right okay Jake The Snake I'm
trying to read your face here you just
said he's expected play I'm getting yeah
I can tell Jake likes to
pick I don't know I'm getting I'm
getting that Trevor Lawrence Vibe for
him I don't know what he's thinking dude
if Trevor Lawrence ever plays a
celebrity poker game it's going to be
over first of all you both of us would
be enamored by that that Lion
Man of hair that he has you know and
then he doesn't need to wear sunglasses
like what in the is this kid
thinking all right well so who you going
with you're going with the the Chiefs I
got the Chiefs Paul I got the Jets
getting nine I got the Colts
laying one I got the the Pats getting
three and I got the Chiefs laying three
and a
half look at
this listen coming on it's
over I'll be honest with you I like your
this week is really tough I like your
picks now I got so far I got three
favorites you know sometimes Paulie
looks at us looks at the board and I I
can't lay off a favorite but that was
old Paulie
though PA likes the old Paulie used to
root for the landlord the new Paulie the
new Paulie's rooting for the
tenant ah you know the landlord built it
up though you he deserves some respect I
got three favorites right now in the
Chargers Giants and Lions and the one
game I see here where a team is getting
some points and Bill mentioned something
about a trap game with the Lions but I
think the Trap game could be the Buffalo
Bills the Buffalo Bills are giving the
Raiders eight points I know it's in
Buffalo and Buffalo's coming off of a
heartbreaker I think everybody's taking
Buffalo
I think the Raiders know it and I'm just
going to take the Raiders on the road
big dogs you know I'm not saying that
Buffalo loses the game I just like the
eight points so I'm gonna take the Las
Vegas
Raiders getting eight points in
Buffalo I know you don't like it
everyone thinks it's gonna be a blowout
no no no no I mean that that game I
stayed away from that eight
points dude I learned my lesson last
year with back door covers I'm not
doing that anymore so you
know yeah I think what you're saying
like I think a safe bet is the bills are
going to win the game but they're not
going to cover and I also think that
they will be covering in the third
quarter and then what then they'll just
do what they always do yeah this
could be yeah this could be a game where
the bills are winning by you know the
bills are winning by 10 points late and
the Raiders do something to try to come
back and and at least at least get the
you know you know covery Jimmy G Jimmy
wins dude he's a winner the guy puts
points on the board Paul you know listen
two reasons the first team I ever played
for I was cornerback for the Raiders uh
when I played Little League Football
peeee League whatever they call it and
uh Jimmy G's Italian you know you got a
goodlooking Italian kid from Las Vegas
coming in there what are you gonna do
he's getting eight points feels
disrespected you know uh he's gonna eat
his grandma's pasta the night before
she's gonna say Jimmy he's not not
familiar with that Stadium he played
there with the
Patriots yep yeah you know and listen
it's the eight points so there you go I
have the
Chargers given three the Giants given
five and a half the Lions given four and
a half and the Raiders getting eight
that looks like I can go 0 and four or
four and0 or anything in week two week
two is like that's that's a difficult
one I I think this is what I have I have
the Jets getting nine yeah I got the
chief laying three and a half I got the
Pats getting three and I got the Colts
laying
one right that's what I got Paul okay
now we got to do the Monday night
special uh there's two right there's two
games two games yeah um can I ask you a
question I I've been out of the country
where the do I watch the games
now ESPN Sunday uh yeah I had to get
YouTube is YouTube just for the package
that's just if you want to watch every
single game dude you know what I love
what the NFL did is they make me get
Direct TV and stick the thing on
the side of my house right and then when
they switch to YouTube they're like hey
no more you know they even say no more
they don't and you don't have to stick a
satellite dish on the side of your house
it's like well you
you're the reason why I have one now
what am I supposed to do with it Paul
it's like an old laptop just sitting
there all the young people walking by my
house snickering look at him he's got a
satellite dish what are you watching the
NFL in 2
19 hey here's another thing Paul when I
was over in uh in Europe you know what
they banned over there that Turf
that we use here too with with the
recycled tires in
it there's lead in those tires oh
and they found that a high rate of
cancer with their their football player
soccer players over there specifically
with the goalies diving now there's no
way the NFL hasn't heard about
that Paul how long do you think it's
going to take them over here where we
feed cows other cows
and propaganda on CNN and Fox News how
long before these corporate
dig up the thing and you
know how long
Paul do I sound like a fringe candidate
I love anytime you stick up for little
people regular people you're a fringe
candidate bill you are on one today dude
this I had a coffee and I'm jet
lagged I got the lines backwards I mean
I don't even know I don't know shot I
don't know who's not I'm like
Chris pen and Reservoir Dogs uh rest his
soul and you know something tell me what
really
happened yeah well that's probably why
you're gonna go four and0 because you're
just on one looks like Sam's Hot Car Lot
outside just because you say it doesn't
make it
so ah paully stop pointing that gu at my
dad I gotta watch that again I
love that movie uh I'm acting like a
professional there's two games bill
there's the Saints and Panthers and the
Browns and by the way the Browns defense
man they're really good deshun Watson's
really good the Browns are no joke
they're on football games giggling like
a bunch of school sorry all right let's
go
um so yeah Brown Steelers it's minus uh
brown brown Steelers are getting to
Steelers are they lay who should we have
taken the Steelers the Steelers are
getting two and a half at home after a
bad loss a bad loss to the 49ers 38 the
over under division rival Browns Browns
Browns look good last week Steelers lost
the itself I hate the
Browns when it comes to money you know
the Steelers s Steelers are the Browns
older
brother okay when are they GNA knock him
out Paul if not now but they got Deshawn
Watson right he just got out of a
massage parlor his balls of light he's
he's on his toes I
like I like the
BR
uh yeah listen I think what we should do
is we should do a Kenny picket touchdown
a Deshawn
Watson actually how about a Nick chub
touchdown Nick chub is playing Jake
yes yes he is um you like the Browns to
win the game by a field goal
bill yeah I think the uh I think the
Steelers I don't know I see them beating
the Browns later on this season I just I
I I don't
know
um at some point dude the Browns just
gotta get this this this this
team off their back I you know I
think DeShaun
Watson the Steelers haven't had to deal
with a guy like that and they're was
looking pretty anemic last week and all
the games I didn't see I'm going to go
with the Browns all right I'm going to
roll with you with that so we'll go
Browns and then we gotta pick two others
and then we got yes 3 38 and a half 38
and a half I don't want to touch all
right so how about
this because this will if this can
happen and this could be money for
people and a lot of people listen
there's nothing me and Bill could do
about last week we didn't know the guy's
leg was going to blow out four plays in
everyone's going hey that Monday night
special blew up pretty quick yeah well
it did I don't know what you want me to
tell you
um kind of a miserable writes that
fall on a injury I can see if he
giv a it's a
injury yeah we both went you know that
guy's date in the hotel blew up pretty
quickly too didn't it yeah yeah they we
both went two and two and guys are like
hey guys rough week one huh I'm going
not really we're 500 not really did you
have the Jags you idiot did you
have the the Lions and the Dolphins shut
up oh what are we we're yelling at
robots they're probably Bots it's
probably not even a person what about
Naji Harris to run one in I think Kenny
picket throws his first touchdown as as
a Steelers starter this year at home
right uhuh all right and what do you
want to do you want to do threw two
interceptions last week you think he
throws another one this
week no I think he'll throw a touchdown
at home dude they went against the 49ers
and they got embarrassed they got
embarrassed by the 49ers dude I think he
throws a touchdown at home I still like
the Browns 49ers are the rich kids this
year they went out and they paid
everybody they they they went George
Stein Paul gang like this
D Who Are You When did we sign we signed
you all right here here his here
it's four million get the out of
here Six
Flags Browns Kenny pick it to throw one
and what do you
think Nick chub anytime touchdown I
think that that's the winner all right
I'm gonna go with that Paul because I
didn't see anything the first
week and
uh I'm I'm I gotta go get a
coffee because I gotta stay up now so I
I can get back I can get
acclimated um all right so then there
you have it so our picks
are Bill Bill you got Bill's picks you
got my picks I got the Jets plus N I got
the Colts minus one I got the Pats plus
three I got the Chiefs plus three and a
half I got the Chargers minus three I
got the Giants minus five and a half I
got the Lions minus four and a half and
I got the Raiders plus eight I like that
Paul that sounds like a balanced dance
card to me even though you you got three
favorite I like it there's something
about those teams I I don't know Bill it
was Chiefs minus three and a half you
said it right three and half
what I just don't want anybody I don't
want anybody hey who Am I who am I I'm
just a guy sliding into 60
wearing his sunglasses uh and a Monday
night special Monday night special guys
we got the we got the Browns minus two
and a half we got the
Ramon we got Kenny pinket to throw a
touchdown for the Steelers and we have a
Nick chub anytime TouchDown for our
Monday night special go to the bmgm app
you could click on you could see mine
and Bill's beautiful faces on that bet
you click on the bet you you put it in
and there you go $10
responsibly yes of course at a level
that could end your marriage yeah next
thing you know you're standing outside a
train station looking for a dick to suck
um all right guys that's our picks for
week two make sure you go to the BET MGM
app you put in a minimum of $10 and you
will get up to $200 in wages even if the
one if the first one loses okay use
bonus code bur2 200 B
r200 you could still go to the Survivor
pool okay it's not going to be for the
the quarter of a million but you could
still get in and get prizes on that as
well same code bur 200 all right and
again download the app very easy 10
bucks you get 200 bet responsibly enjoy
yourself enjoy week two everybody enjoy
week two hopefully the Giants bounce
back and I'm in a better uh I'm in a
better mood next week um I'm loving the
Pats to get their first win
outright I like that too all right now
if I can just just find some kid 30
years younger than me that can show me
how to sign up on YouTube I'll be
watching the game we should do something
Andrew where if one week bill goes 4-0
and I go four- 0 if this show goes eight
and 0 we got to do something where we
send fans a t-shirt or I mean we got to
do something somebody's getting merched
then we lose that's gonna cost us a
bunch of money Paul we ain't gonna go
dude if we go 0 and eight oh we go 0 and
eight 0 and eight you said eight and0 Oh
I thought you said eight and0 no no no I
did no I did I said8 no if I go8 no I
got to buy 10,000 people a
t-shirt that doesn't make sense
hey B mgm's got no you know I we I
figured something you know maybe we
throw maybe we give everybody a little $
five credit last season I bought a pack
of football pencils the classic football
pencils so maybe uh maybe we'll give
those away I don't know Bill can sign
the back of them listen this is why you
don't brainstorm on a
podcast
all right well that is just such your
Italian and Greek blood there
list everybody gets everybody get a
watch you're making all of this
money you're gonna blow all of
it hooking people up and tiping
Dorman Paul why don't we just buy a team
why don't we just buy a team Paul oh
that's great all right guys uh enjoy
football this week tonight's game we
didn't touch but tonight's game is
Vikings Eagles I'll be on a live stream
for the first score of that tonight and
uh I'm a dreamer this one of the liest
used to come out Paul but my heart is
gold bill needs bill needs a nap um all
right guys that's it enjoy enjoy week
two we will be back next week uh with
more picks take
care